we could clone a human i'm not clear as
to why it is a bad idea to go find the
smartest person that's ever lived and
take their dna and try to recreate that
over and over and over again so that we
can solve some of our hardest problems i
think intelligence we have a difficulty
talking about it because we don't want
to admit a big part of it's inherited
there's one person a thousand years that
will be known that lives today satoshi
no many parents look at school as almost
like a babysitter that's why i found a
child labor
child labor yes all right explain this
jesus yeah i think we're going to see
some really wild [ __ ] in the near future
we could potentially be living in the
most important century in history and
that changes everything about what you
think is important to work on all right
guys i'm here with dwarkesh uh i'm very
excited about this conversation i
thought a great place to start would be
around artificial intelligence but not
from maybe the perspective most people
have uh you said something to me
recently that just stuck with me which
is
the problems that computers have
are actually some of the easiest things
for human brains to do and vice versa
some of the hardest problems for human
brains are actually the easiest things
for computers to do explain that a
little bit more yeah well first of all
thanks for having me on i'm really
excited about this
that's such an interesting thing if you
look at the things that ais are really
good at and this is changing a little
bit uh to be fair
if you think of like
calculating like 10 digit numbers you
know computers can do that in like
nanoseconds literally
if you think about just some stuff that
like babies can do right like
recognizing faces
um
grammar like if you think about
chomsky's universal grammar stuff you
know just like how how sentences are
strung together in a way it's really
hard to like actually set up rules that
computers can understand about parsing
grammar trees that's something you know
again babies can do so it's really
interesting um it but this is changing i
don't know if you've seen like the dally
through uh the dally 2 the gpt3 these
like the gpd3 is like actually producing
essays
like it writes essays better than
probably most of the people in my
college um dally's generating art that's
like really [ __ ] cool and so these
are things you would think that oh no
these are the things that are like
humans uh humans expertise and you know
the calculations we can export to the
computers
so i'm i'm not sure which way this is
trending now because yeah it is the
problem that the computers can do the
really tough calculations but they can't
do things like facial recognition uh
something where just we haven't had
enough technology innovation and
eventually the computer will be able to
do both the calculations and also what a
human can do i would think so right
because
well it's really mysterious because if
you think about
you know it sounds impressive to say yo
you can do all these calculations but if
you think about it from a computer
architecture point of view it's like
it's like a few gates to actually do
these like integer edition multiple this
is like trivial stuff in terms of like
how much actual computational hardware
is needed whereas like recognizing a
face i mean just think about like
writing a program to do that directly
you had to train these like huge neural
nets to be able to do that
um yeah so it's actually kind of
mysterious that our brain didn't just
like add a little faculty that's like
yeah we would add big numbers but we i
guess we just never had the evolutionary
pressure to need that capacity
um but yeah i think eventually if our
brains can do it and our brains are
physical hardware why can't we build
artificial physical hardware that does
the same thing our brains can do and it
can do everything we can do it feels
like when we are building the software
and hardware to be able to do this stuff
uh but we have to break down so much of
what the brain does into math and
science for the computer to be able to
actually execute it so if you look at
facial recognition like a lot of the
facial recognition systems they just use
you know 12 points on a phase and that's
what they're doing so it's less about uh
some sort of arbitrary like that's a
face that's not a face this face is a
person a this face is person b and it's
much more mathematical right it's
literally looking at you know sometimes
12 points sometimes more sometimes less
uh to try to get to the granularity of
how does the computer actually recognize
this is the person that it's looking for
this is the the item
there has to be something that fits
within the framework of math right for
the computer to be able to do because at
the end of the day like the computer is
a math system right right right um this
is one of the interesting things uh
between the difference between like
tesla and i don't know if you've heard
of comma ai this is like george hatz's
startup so
like the difficulty with self-driving is
you had to account for all these edge
cases right like you can't have a
you can't have a self-driving car that's
like able to do everything but like
it'll run over a child um 99 accuracy is
really bad 99 it'll hit the child
[Laughter]
um yeah so then you you have to deal
with all these edge cases um which makes
it really difficult like if the computer
had you you've like hard-coded in like
you know the lane lines and everything
but you haven't like gotten to not
killing the grandma you know you're
[ __ ]
is this why tesla has such an advantage
because they have every single tesla on
the road collecting so much data and it
ultimately is just a data problem or is
there other ways to look at it i'm
actually not sure about this but i think
uh the one another interesting thing
tesla does is um uh there's this great
guy who has a blog about engineering
austin vernon and he was writing about
tesla
one of the interesting things he pointed
out is
you look at the way elon musk thinks
about problems of manufacturing they've
built like this
amazing manufacturing machine and it's
really difficult to do that right like
they've got a bigger market cap than all
the other automakers in the us combined
um like there was something about adding
fluff in the top of the cars to make
sure that the whole thing was insulated
and
uh and then you know it was just like
adding so much overhead to the
manufacturing because
robots can't pick up pick up this fluff
and then elon just asked like do we
really need this let's just run some
experiments
like does it actually add insulation and
they realize no it doesn't so just
simplifying the whole process it can be
manufactured fast and efficiently and
reliably and precisely i think there's a
lot of interesting things tesla's doing
elon obviously didn't start out with
ambitions in the 90s to build a car
company he didn't start out trying to
say hey i want to go to mars or create
rockets uh but he does have this uh
apparent skill from a first principles
thinking and kind of a framework how
important is it that elon didn't come
from those industries to
if he had been a rocket scientist or he
had been a car manufacturer and grown up
in you know the ford kind of executive
program like would he have been able to
do this or did it take an outsider yeah
that's such an interesting question
you because
there's like aerospace was such a
stagnant sector for so long
and
so maybe but that's what it takes right
like elon comes from software obviously
he founded x.com which became paypal and
the whole scheme about software is we
want to scale this as fast as possible
we want to make this as cheap as
possible we want the most amount of
people to use it
maybe that mentality just hadn't
pervaded these engineering disciplines
and so
just that attitude he had maybe was the
thing that was most important um because
like the the difference between spacex
and what came before it is like huge it
was it cost twenty thousand dollars per
kilogram to send things to space in the
1990s i believe
and elon brought that down to 2000
that's an order of magnitude difference
like those kinds of differences space i
mean space travel has been around for
decades before then it's like you can
still bring it down in order of
magnitude that's like amazing yeah and
it feels like once he
broke through right and kind of the tech
innovation happened now everyone is like
oh we have all these different ideas we
have uh uh smaller rockets we have
people doing space tourism like like it
was almost kind of the roger bannister
four minute mile everyone thought about
it the second that one person did it
then a bunch of people went and ran the
four minute mile and it feels like elon
kind of did that a little bit with space
exploration yeah that's so interesting
um
there uh jimmy sony has a great book
about the paypal mafia peter like uh
people like peter thiel max lovgen
obviously elon musk about how they
founded this company and how they went
on to do like found all kinds of other
companies youtube linkedin this all
comes out of the paypal mafia
and one of the interesting hypotheses
you can develop about like well why is
it the case that
paypal this one company led to
a whole bunch of other companies in the
form of the founders exited then they
just built like basically half of
silicon valley and now
obviously elon like most of car
manufacturing most of the space industry
so why why was this group of people
such prolific founders and one
interesting hypothesis is
you know maybe it was the fact that
paypal wasn't that successful
in the sense that when they exited
they bought them for i think like a
billion dollars
um which is a good sum of money but it's
not like it's not like you like it's not
like we got about over 50 billion
dollars and so these people who were
super ambitious
they did have enough money to fund their
next businesses but it wasn't enough for
them to feel complacent you know yeah
well it's also most young founders uh we
always point when we think of young
founders we think of mark zuckerberg or
you know whatever but the average age of
a successful entrepreneur in america is
like early 40s right right so you have
experience you have capital network you
have connections like all these
different things um
but also
usually people build their biggest
companies not as the first one and so
paypal right paypal wasn't even actually
elon musk's first company uh but if you
think about it
kind of in some way you have almost
practice he does zip to then he does
paypal right and then all of a sudden by
the time you get to the third fourth
fifth one
you know the playbook you've got the
reputation you've got access to capital
you can attract talent which is
incredibly important yeah and you also
have a [ __ ] ton of experience yes right
yes yes yeah i know that's super
interesting i mean the thing with um
paypal is interesting is that elon
he got kicked out of paypal by peter
thiel and others um but like the
reasoning one of the reasons was uh he
had just like
amazing expectations for the company
could do he literally wanted to remake
the financial system right and if you go
see what he's done afterwards in every
industry he goes into
he just
basically does it from scratch like
takes it to an order magnitude
improvement
um
and you know maybe that's the thing
about like founders who end up being
more successful in their first business
um than elon was with like paypal let's
say they hit it big but it's like social
networking or something like that maybe
we're missing out on a lot of talent
that could be going to like hard tech
you know bio space
those kinds of things but they're just
like you know they didn't have like a
middling exit they just kept you know
they had like a multi-billion dollar
company which is like great but if it's
somebody like elon they could like
remake entire sectors of the economy
maybe these people should i don't know
like be forced to quit at some point
their first startups i do think uh
there's a level of boldness that it
takes to build really really big
companies um and in some way the easier
path was like go build like an ad
optimization you know software uh
you could tell people you wanted to take
it public but like you were hoping that
you know google or facebook was going to
come in and buy it for 4 500 million
dollars maybe a billion dollars and like
amazing yeah but at some point people
stop caring about like the exit value
and i think that's when they say like
what could we really accomplish right
and that's where like the boldness comes
in uh now it's weird because people who
find success some people actually lose
the ambition they lose like the edge and
so you do get a bifurcation like after
somebody has had a successful exit of
any material size they either become
hyper ambitious and go take on crazy
stuff uh brian johnson with a colonel
he sold braintree i think he sold it for
like 800 million or something and then
he was like i want to go solve this like
brain computer interface problem and he
went he completely dedicated you know
his time to doing that he i think he's
the biggest investor in the company put
a ton of money into it uh and obviously
with the hyper ambitious path
but then there's folks who like i'm
gonna go to the beach
right and so it feels like that is a a
fork in the road for a lot of
entrepreneurs is once they've tasted
some level of success you kind of find
out like who's in it for the game and
who was in it for the money dude it's so
hilarious when you hear people talk
about
engineers or founders who've been really
successful in the past and when they
talk about what problem they want to
solve they literally just start from
like first principles what is literally
the most important thing i could work on
it's not even a factor to them like how
implausible does this sound like um
john carmack had a great episode on lex
recently uh john carmichael is like this
legendary programmer probably the
greatest of all time created doom these
other games um
and yeah so he's like he's talking about
like you know once i was done with all
this game development stuff i was
considering what should i do next and i
thought oh nuclear fission is an
important problem oh agi is an important
problem artificial general intelligence
so these are the hardest things a human
being could like endeavor to do right
and you're just like yeah that's one
possibility i could work on um yeah
that's that's one thing about some of
these people who actually do become more
ambitious afterwards is that instead of
just looking at how they can make the
most money they literally just start
from complete first principles what is
the most important thing i could work on
sam altman the former ceo of y
combinator is another interesting
example of this he's i think only in his
30s but
um like right now he's the ceo of open
ai which is like the company that's
releasing all these crazy [ __ ] models
that are changing the ai industry he's
also helping helion build fusion so
that's like not fission this is like a
completely different thing
they're trying to make energy 10x
cheaper than it is now
just like working on the two two hardest
problems you could possibly working on
at the same time it's kind of
interesting when those kinds of people
come around
will we have a return back to that being
the aspiration of a lot of founders like
did the pendulum swing do you think too
much to like the social media consumer
product ad optimization uh kind of end
of the spectrum and now we're seeing a
pendulum swing back to
uh things like
andrew yeah varda yeah uh you know uh a
number of businesses like this hey
hadrian you know we use good online
there's a bunch of them like is the
pendulum swinging back interesting well
i don't know if you've heard this about
um china but one of the interesting
theories i heard about what they're up
to is that you know they're cracking
down on
these like big tech companies in china
like alibaba who knows where jack ma is
right now um
and
and so the question is uh like what are
they up to and one interesting theory i
heard is they want they realize that
the future is in large part going to be
controlled by whoever controls hard tech
right who is making the advancements
obviously ai is part of like i guess the
more computer science aspect of it but
also other things like energy who's
controlling bio right um and they don't
even have the same like sense of
what is correct morally with regards to
like bio enhancement and things like
that so whoever controls those
industries is going to control the
future and one of the interesting the
theories i heard about this is
maybe their idea is
we're going to like
crack down on people going into
programming and software and make them
like almost force them to go into like
these hardware tracks that are going to
be super important in the future
well you see this in their geopolitical
strategy as well like they definitely
have run around the world and tried to
create uh financing advantages uh where
they go to a country uh specifically
they're doing this to a lot of african
nations and say hey we're gonna provide
you a loan uh on some you know
interesting terms and it happens to be
for your report right or for some kind
of critical infrastructure uh
and because we're the financier of it it
gives them incredible leverage or access
um or information into that hardware
right which we don't think of the same
way as we think of maybe like a computer
but like what's more important is it to
be the hardware manufacturer for the
next great you know desktop computer or
is it more important to have a specific
advantage in
very strategic ports around the world
yeah that's such an interesting question
um because
for since world war ii basically the u.s
has been the hegemonic naval power it's
basically said to the rest of the world
like we'll protect the cities for you um
but you're kind of part of our empire
like [ __ ] basically right um and then
yeah china is like trying to turn that
around i happen to think i haven't
looked too much into this but i happen
to think that it's probably a good thing
for
the countries they're going into like
people talk about it as like
exploitative or something and part of it
probably is but also like getting money
on terms uh getting loans on terms that
the rest of the world is not willing to
offer to you
assuming you have good leadership that's
like not just going to squander the
money and then your future country is
left in a bunch of debt
yeah it's like i think that's probably
probably a good thing so like basically
you're saying it could be and again we
got to see it play out but it could be
good for the country bad for the us in
some way yeah yeah who is that what is
the name of that japanese um like crazy
[ __ ] who's uh the venture
capitalist masayushi yeah yeah i wonder
if like china is a masayoshi son of
africa it's just like throwing crazy
money after
uh if you create don't your own money
like why not i saw this uh hilarious
tweet that was like um there's never
been a greater marxist redistribution
effort than
saudi 100 billion dollars of saudi oil
money going to masayoshi who just gives
it to like these stupid ideas about you
know we're gonna like do pet delivery
and antarctic hours you know just like
the craziest ideas yeah yeah well how
much of it is you have to fund the dumb
ideas to get the breakthroughs as well
like you know when elon shows up and
says i'm gonna build a reusable rocket a
lot of people weren't like hey here's
money right he wasn't elon at the time
but but uh also uh there was a hard tech
component to it and i think an
aspirational goal uh that is different
than like food delivery or pet walking
or whatever
but still it feels like you gotta
do quite
stupid deals to get some of the
breakthroughs
right like airbnb is a good example
where
you know if you're investing in two guys
who are like we're renting out air
mattresses in our kitchen
a lot of folks who've been like that's
dumb but then it's followed up years
later and a bunch of venture capitalists
funded like remember juicero no it was
like uh
make juice at home kind of like a coffee
machine but for juice and i forget it
raised an ungodly amount of money and so
of course when it didn't work all of the
critics of the tech industry in silicon
valley were like look at these idiotic
tech bros funding you know a juice
machine why do you need you know 100
million dollars or 200 million whatever
it was
but it was like sure
but you would have said the same thing
about airbnb if it didn't work yes and
so like it's important that they work
because then people look like geniuses
the founders the investors if they don't
work then the critics get ammunition and
they're like you guys are morons i you
know i'd be actually curious about your
perspective on this because you actually
did invest in airbnb what's up guys i
hope you're enjoying this conversation
darkesh has an awesome podcast called
the lunar society you guys should
definitely go into the description you
can subscribe there both on youtube and
to the audio all right let's get back
into the conversation and i hope you
guys enjoy it one thing i've been
wondering about is
if you think about like the stock market
versus venture capital right the great
thing like the reason i expect stock
prices to be like generally correct is
you can short a stock so if it's like
too highly valued some you know somebody
will come in and like short it and so
it'll come to its correct fundamental
value with venture capital there's like
let's say you think that
the marginal venture capitalist is
making
um a stupid deal right like you think
that this company is super overvalued
there's no way for you to short it and
reduce its price to its correct power so
it's like asymmetric in that way prices
can only increase it's similar to like
housing markets where
you can think you can say like i think
sf's like house prices maybe in 2020
you're like i think they're overvalued
right um and but there's no way for you
to like make profit off that knowledge
and so yeah like the market doesn't
correct as easily is that would you say
that's like a correct characterization
of how the vc industry works so there's
correction mechanisms but they're done
in a different way right so public stock
let's say that i'm long it gets
overvalued you're like hey it's
overvalued you can short it and and uh
the theory is that it finds kind of the
equilibrium price of the market over
time um in venture capital because it's
private and illiquid uh people can
invest on specific terms and we've seen
it over the last eight nine months uh
there can be corrections in the market
where companies that raise money at huge
valuations that maybe didn't have the
financial performance or the growth kind
of track record that fit those numbers
from you know the end of 2021
the next round of funding somebody may
come in and say hey i don't think it's
worth you know 2 billion i think it's
worth a billion and so there's down
rounds but it's not done in the same way
of like somebody is uh necessarily
profiting off of the cut in valuation
from 2 billion to a billion it's instead
that the people who actually uh uh are
affected they're affected negatively
it's either the investors who are
investing at 2 billion it's shareholders
that were already you know equity uh
holders of the business um and then
employees
right who thought that hey our equity is
worth two billion or whatever now
actually it's only worth a billion and
so
it's a correcting mechanism but it
because there is no liquid market
there's no shorting mechanism which is
like an interesting you know kind of uh
alteration to eventually trying to
figure out what is the market price i've
got a few friends who work at startups
and how is given the market
basically a lot of their wealth is just
in the equity that the startup is giving
them and at this point it's like not
only is it a liquid but if they sold it
in private markets it would just be
worth a lot less
i mean they're just like sitting like
basically they're like illiquid for the
next few years until like their
companies go public or
yeah or like the market changes or
something i was talking to a friend
recently uh and
he basically was like
i've been trying to figure out how many
of my friends made money in tech i was
like what do you mean and he was like
think about it he was like we happen to
know a very wide spectrum of folks we
know people have been working in the
technology industry for a decade plus
yeah and they've made no money and then
we happen to be uh friends with or know
folks who are the single best investors
in the world and they've been absolute
killing
but if you were to look at the full
aperture of uh the folks we know in the
technology industry
most of them have not made
life-changing money compared to the ones
who have now the ones who have are well
known and it has been explosive you know
kind of profits and so the power law
takes over and those are the people who
everyone points to because oh how much
money you can make in tech
but it probably from an individual
participation standpoint follows a lot
of the distributions like venture funds
it's like i don't forget the exact
numbers but like 50 of venture funds
don't make any money yeah and so if you
were to just bring that to employees
like what percentage of employees in the
tech industry don't make enough money to
uh retire
more than 50 like they're still working
right and so you start to understand
it's just like everything else like
there are people who win there are
people who lose and everyone points to
the extremes but the actual experience
of the everyday kind of average
participant in the market is not what
the extreme is and so people forget that
because they're holding equity but i
think we've seen over the last nine
months like the correction in the market
shows them maybe i didn't have as much
value of this equity that i thought i
had yeah and i think people also
overestimate the upside of
like working at a startup not
necessarily founding a startup or
working at a startup like if you think
about
let's say you get good get on board a
startup that is gonna like gonna grow
like gangbusters i mean the first
challenge is like you basically have to
think like an investor to like even
figure out what startup you want to work
in yes because what they're paying you
in is equity and how you value that
equity is the same way an investor would
value that equity right so you had to
have that skill in the first place which
is like you got to be a great programmer
and you had to know how to value
startups in the market okay so you need
both those skills let's say you have
those skills
okay and then you're an early employee
at a startup they give you like 0.5
equity or something um even if you get
that and even the company exits for like
a billion dollars right which is like
not going to happen like a rare kind of
thing a unicorn everybody's heard of
these companies so even if you happen to
like pick that then you still exit with
like 0.5 uh equity you only get five
million dollars at exit
um whereas if you're that good a
programmer or that good an engineer
you could have just like work for google
for 10 years for the same amount of time
would have taken that exit and you could
have made like a similar amount of money
so or more yeah exactly
and that's actually an interesting
problem i've heard startup founders talk
about which is
given how
much money was flowing around these
markets for the last few years
one interesting challenge is like listen
you want to hire a second employee a
third employee these people are not
going to have like the amount of equity
the founders have so they're obviously
um they're obviously going to be like
less motivated to
get on board your company but like with
your third employee you basically need
him to be like a founder quality person
right you can't just have like some guy
who's come this is eight to five as a
third employee or something but these
people are not going to get the equity
that you're getting so if this person is
good enough to start a startup otherwise
you shouldn't hire them so if they're
good enough to start a startup why
wouldn't they just like raise their own
money to build their own startup this
goes back to uh a lot of the first five
employees they take founder risk without
founder reward right and uh what i found
is the people who are the best second
third fourth fifth hire uh they know
that they're actually not gonna go start
a company
so uh they tend to be younger people who
are saying i wanna learn and then
eventually one day i'll go start my own
company so it's almost like a
apprenticeship
workhorse right um and then the second
thing i would say is
a lot of the best startups in the world
they basically hired their friends
right if you really think you know i uh
i did an interview with david sacks and
i asked him about uh
uh paypal and paypal mafia yeah and i
was like how did you get all of these
people and he was like well no one
wanted to work for us so we just hired
our friends yeah and it just happened to
be they were all you know these amazing
folks and so
i do think um
in hindsight we like to tell these like
really sexy stories about like i knew
that person was gonna go on and found
you know an amazing company and it
happened to be chad hurley who did
youtube yeah and then you find out
you're like uh no like literally we
needed somebody to program and like we
found the smartest person we could who'd
come work for us and like it happened to
be this person yeah and then they went
on and did something amazing yeah so you
have to be careful as to like the
hindsight bias of it looks amazing
but there is a kernel of truth of like
max leption uh elon musk and peter thiel
who were pretty much the the people
making the hiring decisions very early
on
they were great at selecting talent
right and that talent just happened to
them go start companies and everyone
recognized them later on but these three
fellas understood it you know on day one
yeah and it's a really interesting
question of how you spot this talent
this is like something i've been trying
to think about from
like initially from the perspective of
somebody who was like trying to get
opportunities like in college trying to
figure out
you know how can i get spotted and stuff
like that
but i think this is one of the really
interesting challenges
of how you spot people who have talent
but not only that you do you spot people
who others haven't already spotted so
you're just like going to go to like the
harvard job fair you know like people
know these guys are smart right so you
know like everybody else will be there
you want to spot the people other people
don't know
could be as valuable as you think like
just with the paypal mafia people like
joe lonsdale you know wasn't he like
just a stanford student they you know
they got about an internship stuff like
that um
yeah so i think the harvard job fair is
the last place to go look for talent
yeah especially in startups
because if you are at the harvard job
fair
you're looking for a job
right like like that like that's why
you're there right and so to some degree
like actually the better thing to do is
to go to the harvard computer science
lab yeah on friday night at 11 pm and
see who's there didn't paypal actually
kind of do not with harvard i think with
like another university i'm sure they
did i think they basically did something
very similar yeah and i think a huge
piece of this is like you're looking for
the person who's already
doing the job or who already shows a
predisposition to being successful in
this environment
not the person who is showing up and
looking for
uh how big is your organization if i put
on my resume will it look good how much
do i get paid what's my title like it's
just
playing a different game and so what you
want is you want people who are worried
about uh the end result not kind of what
it looks like you're doing yeah yeah i i
always think of this as like the uh the
parent test
do you
are you hiring somebody who cares what
their parents think about their job or
are you hiring somebody who wants to be
able to say to their parents 10 years
from now
do you know that thing that you use
every day
my team and i built that
and those are two different people yeah
right like there are some people who
it's really important uh that their
parents can say to their friends like my
kid does x or my kid is a lawyer or a
doctor or has this big title at some
company yeah
probably not for you know building
innovative technology yeah no i think
what you said there is really
fundamental um i was trying to figure
out
there kyle newport uh has this really
interesting blog post where he points
out
um
like you can think of
you can like let's say you can reverse
this back to college admissions just to
get a sense of how to think about talent
so
if you think about a kid in high school
right
one of the kids is he's like started a
business maybe he has like five-figure
cash flow he might even have like a few
contract uh employees um like i don't
know he builds websites or you know just
like doing something um
and then you have a kid who's like the
president of five clubs and he's on the
varsity tennis team and he's i don't
know like volunteered in ethiopia over
summer um he got a selfie with a with a
shovel um so if you think about those
two people um
why is it the first one sounds more
impressive it's not because he worked
harder because to be a president like
fight clubs or whatever you got to work
pretty hard maybe he's it's not even
necessarily he's more intelligent right
like again you still be pretty
intelligent like excel in high school
get all these great sat scores whatever
so what is what is the difference and
he says it has something to do with
novelty that the second sorry the first
kid the one who's like started this
business he's doing something original
creative shows that he has a vision
ambition
i think that's part of it but i think
there's something even more fundamental
if you think about how a call option is
valued right like call option being the
right to buy something
the right to buy a stock at a
predetermined price so you're basically
trying to maximize the upside if you
think about how call option is valued
what do you care about well you care
about the volatility right
if you have a call of showdown stock you
you might even care more about the
volatility than its actual current value
or expected value because if the stock
is moving around all the time in huge uh
then there's a chance it'll like move up
like you think about like buying a call
option on bitcoin right in like
2015 or something um you just care about
bitcoin being super volatile um because
if it goes to the moon you have all that
outside
and you also want a big time to maturity
so the distance between like where you
know your current date and like when the
call option is exercised again because
there's more room for the
underlying asset to experience large
fluctuations in value you apply that to
talent you think about the kid who is
starting a business in high school that
guy is like way more volatile right so
buying an option on him is like buying
an option on tesla buying an option on
the second kid is like buying an option
on ibm it's just like how far off it's
going to go right like the first kid
could potentially become the next
patrick collison the second kid might
work for patrick collison well it also
goes back to like uh in some way you
have to pick the people that violate the
societal
uh conformism right like the more that
somebody is conforming to what society
thinks you should do uh the less likely
they are to have volatility right or to
have uh the outlier components or kind
of uh um outcomes and so
if you go back and you look at a hell of
a lot of people uh who have ended up
being highly successful they sure didn't
fit kind of the normal box now you have
to be careful because some people are
just weird right or or dumb and their
ideas literally sound insane because
they are insane yeah uh
but there's a lot of folks who are
outside of kind of that normal framework
uh and that's where the volatility lies
and so with volatility it works both
directions
it can go up but it can't go down as
well and so uh to some degree if you're
playing a power law game which venture
capital is
you actually should go make almost all
of your bets on highly volatile uh kind
of opportunities because you only need
one
right which again sounds to the
untrained person uh oh you're gambling
but no it's your understanding the power
law and what you're trying to do is
you're trying to find the highest
volatility you can find and if you pick
correctly
you end up hitting more and more and
more there there's this great movie um
hindi movie that i um it's one of my
favorites it's called once upon a time
in mumbai and it's basically about this
like mafia boss uh and so then he's like
testing out this new recruit and the guy
is just like he's just like a crook the
new guy but he's also like really
ambitious and really creative and then
um so then he recruits him
and one of his like i don't know it's
like basically it's like the mafia
bosses like chief of staff is like that
guy doesn't seem straight that guy seems
like all kinds of wicked and the lafay
boss is like well we have no room we
have no need for straight people in our
business
yeah
but the dangerous thing is yes you want
to take these leveraged bets on people
the thing about leverage you know you
can think of like a 10x engineer as
not not just meaning it's like 10x
better but like apply the literal
financial definition so you have like a
3x snp fund you can have like 10x
leveraged tesla think about it's like
actual financial leverage
that's not always good right it's good
if you have um if you've made a great
bet if you made a great bet on um like a
company you're really sure about your
vision leverage can amplify your returns
but if you've made the wrong vet you're
just going to get liquidated faster
think about like somebody like napoleon
so
if uh the the after the revolution the
government in charge of france was a
directory and they made a highly
leveraged bet in the person of napoleon
right so he gave them stupendous returns
austria italy even like went to egypt
like fought under the shadows of the
pyramids
um but
it was a leveraged bet there's a big uh
downside one of which is he'll return
and he'll get rid of the entire
government and replace it with his own
dictatorship
um but what kind of person did you think
was going to be the one that's going to
conquer all of europe for you so yeah i
think it's like really potentially
rewarding but potentially very dangerous
to hire those kinds of people elon said
this on snl he was like i'm trying to
like save humanity and go to mars like
did you think i'd be normal
right like i thought it was like like
that's the most honest thing that i
think anyone could say on national
television it's like no we shouldn't
think that you're normal and that's why
you think that you know uh i saw a clip
recently his birthday is exactly 69 days
after 4 20.
and he was like this is a simulation
right and it's like of course this guy
thinks it's hilarious right so i i don't
know it's a very weird thing you wrote a
piece about uh miracle years and i found
this fascinating where a number of great
scientists and inventors uh they
basically had majority of their
breakthroughs in a very compressed
period of their career describe a little
bit this idea of like miracle years and
then like why do you think this is uh
something that plays out no it's such an
interesting um
it's such an interesting pattern yeah
that piece went like
super viral more than i was expecting
but i it was just one of these
interesting patterns you notice in the
world and once you notice that you can
start kind of start thinking it makes
you maybe shift your perspective on
certain things maybe come up with entire
different theories about how to explain
different institutions
but yeah so this is a really interesting
pattern in
the careers of scientists not only
scientists but especially scientists
you see somebody like isaac newton age
of 21
pandemic hits oxford he's sent home
comes up with theory gravity calculus
starts making progress versus optics it
said that by the way he he created
calculus at the same pace that the
college students learns calculus
wow yeah uh all in one year at the age
of 21 um uh einstein age of 26 he's like
phd kind of got rejected he's been
sidelined out of an academic career so
he's a patent caller
as a patent clerk
he comes up with he he explains that
photoelectric effect comes with special
relativity brownian motion
um there was another important paper um
i think it was about avogarato's
constant but anyways
four fundamental results like super
important results in the history of
science 26 one year um and it's not just
science i mean there's other scientists
who've had such miracle years von
neumann goss euler but you look at the
careers i don't know if you saw the
brandon sanderson thing
okay well do you know like he's a
fantasy um
he's a fantasy author probably the like
the biggest fantasy author these days he
um since the pandemic started like two
years ago he he announced on youtube
he's written five extra novels that his
fans didn't know he was writing in
addition to the ones he they already
knew he was writing the kickstarter to
accessing novels he releasing them as a
kickstarter
40 million dollars
wow biggest kickstarter in history okay
anyways so what is happening here why is
um why are these people having these
extraordinary years where they make um
progress towards seemingly independent
problems in such a short span of time
there's a lot of interesting hypotheses
here one is
maybe there's like a brief window in a
person's life
where they're young enough to have
creativity
intelligence you know your intelligence
kind of declines as you get older
um ambition
um but also they're like mature enough
to kind of understand what's going on
the field it's similar to what you said
with um
elon going into these new fields
applying first principles thinking so
maybe there's like a brief window in a
person's life where they can do that and
maybe it's like only a couple years in
your entire life right and if those
years you're concentrated you're able to
work on the problem you're gonna make a
[ __ ] ton of progress
um there's other hypotheses you can make
like one is maybe just like a super sad
story about
let's say you become successful right
let's say you win a nobel prize let's
say you become department head or
something okay what does that mean well
you've got like a bunch of obligations
that are sucking on your time your
energy you got to like attend
conferences write pop side books just
like do interviews um like deal with you
if you're a department head you have to
do all this administrative stuff and
that's one thing where like maybe your
universities are really [ __ ] up
because like maybe even like now the
grad students are getting mired up in
all this like extracurricular duties so
one thing is this like your success
brings obligations that like destroy
your capacity to do productive work
um and yeah there's a few other
interesting rabbits i mean one thing is
that maybe these just problems are just
linked with each other like
maybe you the photoelectric effect and
special relativity and browning motion
they're kind of you start thinking a
certain way and all of these things just
fall out you know they're like basically
the same branch of a tree but i think
it's such an interesting pattern like we
really don't need how much of it is just
they went through some event like you
just mentioned uh a pandemic hits you
get ordered to go home uh your thesis
gets denied essentially uh and so
there's like a um a negative event
that then forces you to uh refocus or
prove people wrong or some effect
or also
its focus gets sent home obviously the
last two years with the fantasy writer
right sitting at home during the
pandemic like
i i do think there's a lot of weight in
today's society too
i break distractions into two buckets
there's like distractions we recognize
and then distractions that uh we don't
think of as distractions and so
distractions we recognize are simple
notifications on your phone you're
bullshitting on you know doom scrolling
on twitter you're watching netflix like
you're doing all these things that
you're like this is mindless activity i
may enjoy it but like it's definitely a
distraction from productive work right
then there's things which some of you
actually mentioned uh email meetings
conferences like obligations we don't
think of those necessarily as
distractions because we think that
there's some reason why we're doing
we've explained to ourselves that it is
an obligation and that's why i'm doing
it
but if you actually just look at both of
those activities as distractions and say
whether i'm doom scrolling or i'm at a
conference that i feel obligated to go
to yeah and you just pull all that away
how much more productivity how many more
breakthroughs could people have
in any industry by simply just focusing
yes yeah i know this is such a great
point um
like
there's uh
my friends in tech some of them are like
starter founders you know they're like
going to this conference here and like
grabbing coffee here and um
the question is like what is what is a
per what is your purpose on earth right
now like what what is the thing you're
trying to maximize right um are you
trying to get more users or like let's
say with a if you're like a content
creator you're like trying to get more
people to hear your content um
you have like a specific target you're
trying to achieve how does like grabbing
coffee with a random person fulfill that
goal um not that you shouldn't do it but
you should understand that like that is
not your job right that is not the thing
you're like put on earth to do at that
particular moment
um yeah and i i think uh i think it's i
think another interesting thing is i i
wonder if like like people listen to a
lot of podcasts and audio books and
stuff like that i wonder if that i
honestly don't have a good opinion yet
of should i think of that as a
distraction or should i think of that as
oh it's helping you think about the
world it's not making you more creative
so on um because i i think like a big
part of the reason people is the podcast
obviously not this one other podcast um
is like just vicarious
like you vicariously just want to
participate in like a conversation like
with friends or something it goes back
to like the the stoic argument of like
how painful is it to sit by yourself
with nothing right um and i don't know
about you but for me uh
i
put aside intentional time to go for a
walk outside and i don't look at my
phone
and what i have noticed is like
value per minute
on that walk
is off the charts compared to any other
activity i do it has nothing to do with
what i'm actually doing yeah sure
there's science of your walking your
brain you know and all this activity
whatever but it's actually just like my
nose isn't in this super computer in my
pocket and trying to figure out you know
what's going on in the world and so it
goes back to like focus and clarity and
all these things
it's just that the incentives and
literally the way our brains are wired
is to get the dopamine hit or just think
about like people say they get their
best ideas when they're taking a shower
it's not because there's something
magical about like water running down
your face that makes you more creative
is that that is the only time in your
day
that you are not hearing the input of
other minds right that is the only time
you're for most people you're driving
you're listening to music you're
listening to podcasts for you know you
get home you're on youtube blah blah
blah um you're at work meetings
how much of your day in like actual
minutes is you not consuming the input
of other minds
do you think that many of the scientists
inventors and kind of innovators of the
past they had just made distractions
they didn't have super computers in
their pocket but they had other things
that served as distractions or do you
think they just naturally given the lack
of technology accessibility that we have
today they just had less distractions
and therefore i spend more time thinking
i think that's got to be it right like
if you um
it just like would physically not be
possible
you're like walking somewhere you can't
like plug in something in your ears
it just like physically would not be
possible to uh occupy all your time with
uh the input of other minds right um or
if you're doing it you have to do it in
like a very intentional way of like i'm
gonna engage this person in conversation
yeah it's almost an interesting thing
about like
it's so almost unrelatable if you
actually had to spend some time in a
previous era me having grown up with
like these technologies um it's almost
like hard to relate to some uh i'm just
i'd just be very curious about the
day-to-day of somebody like that i also
wonder how much of the breakthroughs
that we've seen in math science hard
technology uh in prior years and decades
even centuries comes from the sheer
number of people focused on those
problems versus now going back to our
conversation earlier how many of our
smartest folks are thinking about
other things like a great example how
many intelligent people are focused on
building facebook instagram
uh google tik tok and like ecommerce
sites no
i probably just nailed about i don't
know 30 of like the tech industry right
or whatever it is and again it's not to
say that like google search has this
amazing mission of like getting people
information and like doing all this
stuff but
there is a very strong argument that
those companies and technologies take
talent away from nuclear power or from
space exploration or something else and
so it's hard to compare and contrast
like which one is like better for
humanity right uh because they're
different things
but there's definitely something to the
fact that like a portion of our smartest
people or the people who would have
those breakthroughs they're not working
on certain things because they've chosen
to work on other things yeah i have a
hard time thinking about
what i should um because you know i went
to india earlier this year
and you know we get out of the airport
and we're i you know i get in the car
and um the driver pulls up google maps
and i'm like no way that [ __ ] works i'm
like the roads in india like you got
these
like half the roads are just filled with
people so you can't even drive on them
like how how could this possibly i think
no no it's actually getting pretty good
it's uh you could actually use this for
navigation and basically at least all
the big cities and stuff and you know
this is a technology developed in
silicon valley by these people um who
are like you know just like hard coders
not working on these hard tech things
but now it allows
this guy in india to navigate the
difficult streets
you know probably makes his quality of
life much better and all kinds of helps
to make money economic uh mobility
exactly so
there's i think a lot of indirect ways
in which big tech is actually really
good all around the world especially
around the world because um if you look
at um facebook's revenue for a user in
america what is it like it's like
wasn't it like 20 per month or something
like that in like india it's probably
like less than a tenth of that so
they're probably losing money on working
in these emerging markets but american
consumers are actually subsidizing them
being one of their products for the rest
of the world yes
um so but i don't think that it's a
big tech is bad like that i think that
argument
other than maybe the most extreme
uh kind of folks that are critics of
silicon valley believe that but outside
of that i think everyone realizes like
hey these companies are net positive for
society and like how privileged are we
to argue about uh disinformation in the
united states when literally these some
of these products are the you know
whatsapp is the way that the world
communicates you know in many countries
and so uh it you know it's a first world
problem right uh but
that doesn't mean that the companies
behind it or the work they've done are
net negative it just means that nothing
is 100 positive like everything
hey there's cars that get in car crashes
should we not have cars like no we
probably should have cars and make them
safer right yeah and so uh it's just
though that
at what point is the incremental
engineer that goes to one of those
companies the output or productivity
that they provide is not nearly as much
as if they went and worked in another
industry that maybe doesn't have as many
people or the problem is harder or can
affect more people i think that's a
great point like i think once the
industry's mature they get really good
at recruiting people so you know
if you're like i just graduated computer
science if your computer has certain you
know exactly what to do to get a job at
facebook or google or you know you're
just like you go to the job fair you
give them your resume you know exactly
what you need to do in terms of
internships so you get a job there um
where it's like if you want to if you
just want to think a college student's
like first principles he's thinking what
is the most important thing i could be
working on there's not like an obvious
way in which you're like that the
nuclear fusion guy's going to show up to
your job fair right so i think once
these industries get big companies get
big they they're really good at
recruiting which means they get more
talent because they've gotten good at it
which means that the new industries like
they don't have the time or the
knowledge to
actually be able to recruit these people
effectively
um which if you are that kind of and
also they don't have the prestige right
like there's a certain kind of procedure
associated with like working at google
or like i think it's similar with like
finance people and like working like
mckenzie or goldman sachs um
and so i if you are one of these small
companies i think one like it's very
important you develop an edge
of you can't just recruit the same
person that like google knows to recruit
you can't just like be looking at oh
these guys are like really intelligent
and he's like hard working and he has
like good internships on your resume
because every other company is looking
for the same thing right you need some
like with the paypal mafia right you
need some unique edge so the unique way
to think about talent that helps you
find the people that google would have
ignored or facebook would have ignored
like one when people say harvard is
selective
or like google is selective it's
elective in the sense that they've
rejected a lot of people but often these
are the best people
often they're optimizing for the wrong
thing like who is doing selection it's
like some humanities person
um people who write college essays know
exactly how to game this [ __ ] right um
so
yeah you have to have that in edge if
you want to beat out these prestigious
institutions paul graham talks a lot
about uh many people have to
learn unlearn what they learned or like
learn to unload right and it's because
uh
in one of his essays he talks about
people who get to y combinator and they
would say okay like basically what is
the test right tell me what like like
how do i
do this so that i'm quite successful
he's like that's the problem like your
entire life you were taught okay come to
class take notes take the test
regurgitate what you learned in class
and in your notes on the test you know
here's your uh a move on to the next
thing and you just kept doing it over
and over and over again he goes but now
like there is no test
right it is actually a ambiguous
environment
where there's multivariate uh inputs
that you then have to synthesize and
figure out the answer but the answer is
not you know uh the teacher or some
standardized test is determining the
answer the answer is what do the
customers want the customers are an
ever-changing you know kind of target
they can
like one thing on day one and they can
like something else on day two they may
like different severities they could
actually say you know what you both have
uh you and your competitor have similar
products but price becomes a component
or maybe it's quality like you have to
figure all this stuff out
people who are good at school suck in
that environment
and so i actually think that the reason
why google and uh uh places like
mckinsey or goldman or whatever become
so
great at recruiting is because they're
pulling from the largest pool most
people do not want to take risk they do
not want to be the outlier and they do
not want to uh go and uh have failure
yeah and so what is the quote-unquote
safe thing to do go work at a place
where
you can go home and you're not worried
about whether they're paying payroll or
not
you go home and you tell your parents
hey i work at goldman sachs hey i work
at google right uh and you work on
something that is interesting enough
because you're in this environment where
somebody has told you like this is the
most important thing or this is a
prestigious thing to do
and so like you're satisfied because you
almost don't know anything else
and so one of my favorite things to do
is talk to people who are graduating
college like i want to go be an
investment banker
and i'm like have you ever like spent
time with investment bankers like like
go and like oh i did an internship i'm
like cool tell me about the internship
like was it fun and they're like well
you know we like do like a lot of like
happy hour things and like it was like
kind of interesting whatever and i'm
like your job is gonna be happy i'm like
okay
and then i'll talk to him like a year
later and i'd be like hey how's it going
and like this is hard right like yeah no
[ __ ] it's hard right like they they are
going to burn through a bunch of these
young people and some people enjoy it
and stay and other people churn out that
doesn't mean people shouldn't go into
investment banking or anything like that
but what it does mean is that along that
path there's a lot of people who opt out
they thought they wanted one thing and
they changed their mind
i think
society would be much better off if we
made it
more normal for people to take bold risk
yeah
the problem is
failure
is a negative yeah and so most of
society looks at it you tried something
you failed you're an idiot yeah instead
if we just said look everyone's a
scientist
go run experiments and by the way if you
run an experiment it's not that you
failed except the experiment didn't work
imagine how much further along we would
get and how much quicker we would be
able to create progress innovation in
various pieces of technology if everyone
was encouraged to try the boldest
craziest ideas they had and if you
failed or the experiment didn't work
it's fine go again yeah this goes back
to what you said earlier about
we judge these ideas which didn't work
as bad
when before they sounded just as crazy
or just as good as airbnb
afterwards you know if airbnb had failed
we could say like come on you're gonna
let strangers live in your house like
that's stupid um
i think that's true of like a lot of
things you could work on
where the the difference is just you
know there is an element of luck or just
like the things you learn over time um
where if airbnb had failed like yeah
they'd get they had like you know they
had like what like uh tens of thousands
of dollars in credit card debt so they'd
probably be in like bankruptcy court or
something at this point if airbnb be it
failed um yeah so then you could just
like laugh at them but uh there's like a
lot of counter facts if you're trying to
do something really ambitious like in
most cases you'll probably fail right
you're trying to make that small
probability bet that this thing really
explodes and that the small probability
makes it worth it but
yeah then it's you shouldn't judge
people who just ended up on the wrong
side of that equation
we as an entire society went from the
underdogs
to the incumbent right and
i always think about the idea of like uh
everyone starts out as the underdog as
the competitor as the upstart but if you
live long enough you either die or you
become the man right so bill gates was
the kid in the garage trying to disrupt
folks
now
the internet is like bill gates is the
evil billionaire and he's like in a
microchip everybody right
and so when you when you view that
countries can do that societies can do
that and if you were to look at um the
energy around innovation and progress
and uh kind of taking bold risks and
this experimentation
in a country like nigeria in a country
like india or a country like america it
doesn't mean that there's none in
america but it definitely means because
of demographics because of the the lack
of anything really to lose
there is incredible energy and so i
believe that in the united states if we
can get back to that the problem is
there used to be one place in the
country where that was heavily
encouraged which was silicon valley
and people could go there and you could
fail over and over and over again and no
one judged you for it it's just like
cool what's your next idea like i don't
even want to talk about the other one
like what's the next one yeah because
all power law
as that gets dispersed around the
country it goes one of two ways probably
either one other places learn that and
then we get multiple kind of areas of
innovation uh or
it disperses and kind of fades away and
we just become you know the fat cat that
is right for disruption right um
yeah the reason that silicon valley it
has a spirit because if you're wrong and
you've like publicly criticized a person
you're like this won't work right
if you're wrong it's like really like uh
um
who's the founder of anadrol but what's
his name andrew palmer lucky lucky did
you see the thing about him going on
jason clark coming up
and jason
that's gonna that's the next two decades
that's gonna be the feud is like palmer
lucky will never let that die and jason
is also gonna not just let
palmer turn him into a punching bag so
like they're gonna keep going at it in
five decades the hilarious thing is
like jason tries to keep on like twitter
and on his way he like tries to like
turn it around by like saying nice
things about palmer and every time he
does palmer just responds in the most
brutal way like but that's that's the
thing right like if you're like um i i
don't want to like judge jason in
particular i don't know the details but
let's say you're the kind of person who
judges someone too harshly too early and
you're like oh this guy's an idiot this
thing's not gonna work if it does work
you look like a [ __ ] idiot right yeah
it's talking about it's still gonna
value happened so often that like people
are like really averse to judging people
who fail
um yeah where's the rest of the world
somebody doing something crazy i was
talking to somebody who's um a software
engineer in the uk and he was talking
you know where this conference where
people were like had these all kinds of
cool ideas you were saying you know if
this was in the uk and somebody came up
with like an idea like i want to build
like a defense startup or something
people just like laugh him out of the
room right there's this there's this
like tall poppy syndrome um so i think
america has still like conserved that
spirit quite well actually um even in
india because of the hierarchical like
caste system kind of thing i i think
like bangalore and other places that are
like startup hops they're probably
different but similar like silicon
valley is different from the rest of
america or was
but yeah i think america is still
um like surprise like
it's like if you're here it's being a
fish in water but if you go to the rest
of the world and you ask people go to
japan or singapore or something how many
of you want to start your own business
no hands raised you come to the us and
you like just go to a random room how do
you want to start your own business at
some point people might not do it
they're going to raise their hand right
so yeah it's almost like americans uh to
some degree almost have like more
arrogance like everyone raises their
hand but only half of them do it yeah
right have you seen those polls about
they'd look at american kids and nation
kids and
they asked them like are you better than
average in math and like all the
american kids raise their hand
and the asians are like a quarter raise
their hand or something who's better
right but like the generalizations end
up having some kernel of truth right um
the other thing too about i think
american like ambition and innovation uh
is there is a uh resurgence i think
where we hit this low and now you see a
bunch of these companies that are coming
up over the last three or four years
where uh they're taking big swings
remains to be seen whether they'll be
successful or not but i do think that
this like uh almost renaissance uh to
some degree uh is important
but it's coming from the entrepreneurs
it's coming from the innovators and kind
of the scientists and all that it's not
coming from the politicians or the
government
and what's fascinating to me is that in
the mainstream conversation the
conversation has very much shifted in
america over the last 50 years to like
what can the government do for yeah
right
but there's almost like this little
group and you can almost think of it
like you know there's the general
military and then you have like the navy
seals like we need the navy seals to
continue to be ambitious and go do the
[ __ ] that no one else wants to do right
we need this the select group of
startups to be highly ambitious and go
try to drive innovation and do the
impossible
because the rest of society is one not
going to do it they don't have the risk
appetite to do it and actually they're
they're shifting the other way and
there's this rise of oh now we're gonna
get free money like you know when's the
next stimulus bill coming yeah and so i
think that it's like a very interesting
thing
but it it's not a story that's over yet
yeah um no that's the like not only does
the entrepreneurial part of society have
to
like be powerful but like
just to keep up with
all this redistribution and all this
like not even redistribution in the rent
seeking right it's the infrastructure
build like the money in there it's not
like it's getting redistributed it's
just like who knows where it's going um
like some contractors like really
wealthy and happy now but
are there any more trains or railroads
or bridges that are gonna get built
we'll see um there's actually um
i think that after the 2009 bill for uh
the stimulus in 2009 they had they gave
like 30 billion dollars to build train
tracks in uh in the us and zero new
miles were built so literally if you
just do the equation 30 billion divided
by zero miles it costs infinity dollars
to build a mile of railroad in america
but yeah so you this part this is like
the productive part of society they're
actually building new goods and services
they need to keep growing exponentially
just to keep up with the rent seeking
from the rest of society but the
optimistic white pill is
since they're growing exponentially over
time they'll become more and more
important now maybe they become
entrenched and maybe they become part of
the new
establishment but hopefully like elon's
the wealthiest person in the world right
now right hopefully more and more power
goes to these kinds of you know people
who are like building stuff doing cool
things i mean that's a white pill if you
think of elon and jeff bezos right those
are the two um that battle back and
forth on the wealthiest person in the
world like there's a reason why they're
the wealthiest no amazon is an
incredible business that i can press a
button on my phone and something shows
up the next day like that is insane
you probably should be one of the
wealthiest people in the world right
and so i think uh
if you look at the top i think it's the
top 25 of the force 400
none of them
day traders or like investment types
right it's all again power law it's the
people who built highly innovative
products or who are in the family
lineage right it's like the walmart
family uh they end up being um each one
of the walton uh siblings is up on that
list pretty high but somebody in their
family lineage built walmart which you
know is similar to an amazon yeah no i
think that walmart is an excellent
example of you know there's this
economist thomas piketty who wrote this
book capital in the 21st century was
hugely influential a few years ago and
the point he was making is
over time
um in societies what happens is wealthy
people will accumulate resources they'll
hand them down to their kids they'll
communicate resources and the rate of
return to capital if you think about the
s p growth rate is higher than the rate
at which the price of labor grows so
over time they will like this so that is
more and more unequal more hereditary
and he doesn't talk about this but it's
also true that there's like a genetic
component to this um children of
wealthier like uh more successful people
are also likely to be more successful
and so in that way like even there's
like a genetic endowment that uh excuse
things if you look through history most
of the
there's so often a complete drawdown of
wealth because of war because of
revolution because of some crisis um and
then the the either the scales get
completely leveled or the resources are
redistributed
interestingly i think america is the
only country in the western world maybe
the entire world but the only country
where there hasn't been a complete just
regis like complete drawdown of wealth
that you don't just like reset to zero
that hasn't happened in america which
maybe makes us more optimistic but also
more
um
more maybe not cognizant of like the
actual risk that civilization is taking
but yeah so but the walmart is actually
a great example of this because the the
family as a whole is really rich right
but like each individual a wall tonight
is
they're not the richest people in the
world the richest people in the world as
you just said are the people who just
like recently made their money which
goes against the picketing thesis the
the the um but is that not in a
technology age will that not continue to
happen yeah where uh because of the rate
of change and improvement in technology
and the constant reinvention i mean if
you look
tiktok is now the most popular website
in the world yeah that didn't exist 10
years ago right
and so because of that occurring the
incumbents are actually at a
disadvantage to remain the wealthiest
now they're still going to be rich right
uh or their companies will still be
powerful and have a lot of resources uh
but actually the advantage is to those
who have speed and can continue to
reinvent using the new technologies and
just naturally because of the
innovator's dilemma the incumbents
likely don't do that as well as kind of
new upstarts yes i think that's the key
like people complain uh when people
complain about wealth inequality whether
when they say like the wealthiest point
one percent has so many of the resources
what they're not considering is that
point one percent is changing all the
time right that would be really
concerning in a country where there
isn't that level of turnover like you
talked about i think in italy if you
look at
the wealthiest people in the country in
like the 1600s or something there's some
guy did this brilliant study where he's
like looking at the last names and he's
like okay who are the wealthiest people
in italy today who are the wealthiest
people in 1600 i think like most of the
top 25 or something
i like literally direct descendants wow
so like from 1600 to now in a country
where there's like no economic growth
basically
one of my friends put it this way europe
is like a living museum
which is part of the reason why people
like to visit right yeah but but if
you're going to be in the technology
industry i think there's a lot of people
who say hey that's a disadvantage then
maybe somewhere else yeah you've done a
lot of interviews around uh long-termism
uh what is that concept like why are you
so fascinated with it what's up guys i
hope you're enjoying this conversation
with darkesh he's got an awesome podcast
that i listen to regularly called the
lunar society you can go down into the
description click on the link there to
either youtube or the audio all right
let's get back into the episode i hope
you guys are enjoying it yeah i know i
think um this is going to be the things
that we're really going to start talking
about in a few years um and i think this
is this is really interesting and
important to think about
you look at um
we start tend to think about the world
like what's gonna happen in 10 years
it's gonna be in 20 years so it's gonna
happen in 50 years but if you think
about like how long the civilization
could exist
thousands maybe millions of years
billions of years right like
civilization could hang around for as
long as the universe exists and it's
like 10 to the 500 power years until
like all the all the protons into koa
and there's like nothing left
um so that gets really abstract if you
think that far out but you just think
like we want civilization to be around
in a thousand years right we want
civilization to be flourishing we want
people you know we just want all kinds
of creative cool things to happen just
think about how much the world has
changed like the last thousand years
we've grown so much wealthier life is so
much better
just think of that process could
continue longer
um and it's really interesting you can
start to think from first principles
because you can't just extrapolate
trends if you're talking that far out
you really think about first principles
of like what is gonna matter in the long
term it's gonna be things like if we
build through human enhancement or
through ai things that are way smarter
than us
that's gonna be a big deal uh if you go
extinct because of the pathogen because
of nuclear uh war because of you know
other kinds of disruptions that's gonna
be a big deal um
which allows you to ignore actually a
lot of the day-to-day news like
if you look at a newspaper from 100
years ago how much of the stuff they're
talking about actually mattered in the
long run
um same thing like if you open the new
york times like what are the odds that
any article there is going to be
something that 100 years from now people
are going to be like that actually was
important to think about at the time
zero chance right so then you start
thinking about like what matters in the
long term because if most people are
going to live in the future and if
people are like worth roughly equally as
much most of the value that could
potentially exist exists in the far
future we want to make sure those people
flourish as much as possible there's all
kinds of interesting ideas about how to
make sure their lives are good um like
what is that idea like how do you make
their lives better today yeah so one
thing is just making sure civilization
doesn't get stained right like they
can't exist if civilization goes extinct
um but there's a big debate and this is
why this field is really interesting to
me there's huge debates about how to
make sure that the future goes really
well and the good thing is like it's not
mired in like politics or anything
people are just thinking from like first
principles one interesting debate um
there's an economist tyler cowan who
says that over the long term the only
thing that matters is economic growth so
you want to maximize economic growth a
really interesting anecdote he gives is
between 1880 and 1990
if you if the rate of economic growth in
the u.s has just been one percent lower
per year so you know like
that's like a normal range of
fluctuation right just one person lower
every single year
the us in 1990 would be as rich as
mexico was in 1990 per capita right wow
so over time the rate of economic growth
is the thing that matters most but the
um so right now the rate of economic
growth is like two percent approximately
worldwide and it's slowing down which is
really concerning
but this just raises an interesting
prospect because if you think about like
two percent growth that's like the
economy is doubling every 35 years how
long can you keep doing that like you're
doubling every 35 years um you keep
doing that for maybe like the next 100
years maybe the next 200 years can you
keep doing that for the next thousand
years how about the next 10 000 years
because if you extrapolate two percent
growth from our current economy to like
8 000 years from now that would mean
that every single atom in the galaxy had
to support
as
as much economic value as the entire
world has today
right so um which means that like
probably this rate of growth can't
continue for
forever which means
the the times that there's a lot of
growth lots of things are changing lots
of new technologies are coming about
lots of new political incisions are
coming out that may be the most
important time in history because like
that determines what happens in the far
future so we could potentially be living
in the most important century in history
and that changes everything about what
you think is important to work on
because right now if we can
one the economic growth already uh
could potentially make that argument but
if we could increase economic growth
through technology and other innovations
uh then definitely it puts a emphasis on
the current moment yes or just think
about like let's say we develop ai right
um full ai i think there's actually a
good chance that happens this century
like it would like full artificial
intelligence not like hey i have a
startup and i use the term ai and like i
don't even know what that means which by
the way uh there have been people who
pitched me ai startups and i say uh this
isn't ai this is machine learning and
they say no it's ai and i'm like okay
how do you do it and then they just like
literally textbook description of
machine learning like just linear
regression or something like okay uh and
by the way like i'm not an expert right
you know i can
like google all right and so like i do
think that this whole thing of like
actual artificial intelligence is uh
what seems to be
much further off than i think most
people realize yeah yeah there's do you
think it could happen this century oh
yeah i think it's actually more likely
than not why
because if you just extrapolate
the
trends in ai you think about
gpt3 example able to write like full
essays you think about how much more
powerful that is in gp2
um they think they've raised the
parameters by an order of magnitude or
something and it's just so much more
powerful you do that like two or three
more times you raise your order
magnitude i think the training cost of
gpt3 was like 10 million or something
which is like you're talking about
potentially on the track of building the
most powerful technology in history
that's nothing right think about when
people start throwing real money at it
the idea that you could just scale a
model like gbt3 to agi it's called a
scaling hypothesis the basic idea is you
just make this [ __ ] bigger
um eventually it'll get smarter and
smarter until it's agi you make what
bigger you make the training sets or
just like the amount of parameters in
the model okay
i actually had a guy in the podcast
recently who actually did an estimate of
this of you think about the
computational capacity of the brain
and you think about how big these models
are um or how much computational
capacity they use we're only a couple of
orders of magnitude away from actually
having enough computation to run and
emulate the brain that doesn't
necessarily mean we'll like actually
know how to do it um so that's why
there's a lot of uncertainty there
um but if that happens like this this
thing could be seriously smarter than we
are we had to really make sure that it's
aligned um it's a lot like aligned with
our goals um
and another interesting thing like which
would make this century really uh really
impactful and this i think is a near
certainty
is human enhancement of
um i just had this guy on my podcast
it'll be released next week stephen shu
he's working on genomic prediction the
basic idea is
um you'd uh instead call embryo
selection you basically do ivf in
in virtual virtualization you have
multiple embryos you select the one that
has the greatest potential to become
like really smart right you do that over
and over again
over time you can get like
somebody you can make somebody who's
like way smarter than somebody who's
ever existed by just selecting for all
the genomic sequences is that
controversial to do oh yeah
well the the idea is oh the people are
going to afford this are the rich people
um if you do that then like the rich
people will be like get actual genetic
entrenched advantage over time
but it's just like just it's not that
expensive like just give it give it to
everybody for free right um but but like
the actual act forget who's doing it for
a second right like
if
we have a
human race and our goal is to improve
the human experience right like whatever
we're optimizing for is like constantly
improve constantly progress
one huge input is to have
intelligent
humans
operating in the world
on top of that
you want people who uh have very
specific
components right or kind of uh uh inputs
into it that aren't just intelligence
and so what those are obviously there's
gonna be debate right who gets to
determine how do we measure
do we know with certainty is it
probability whatever but there's some
framework that we're like cool
these people will become more productive
members of society and it feeds back to
i have uh i have a friend who will go
unnamed who believes that it is elon
musk's duty to humanity to have as many
children as possible because he's elon
musk and we need as much intelligence as
possible and so like he's a pretty good
person to like put put some life out
there and he's doing a pretty
i think he's in double-digit kids which
like you know hasn't been seen for a few
centuries on average uh but if you think
about this idea it's like okay
i think what makes it controversial to
people is to your point one who's doing
it right like the cost uh um barriers
but also too like i think it just scares
people that like what you mean that we
as humans could have some element of
contribution to the increasing
intelligence of humanity
because i it makes us feel better to
almost think like okay you know uh two
people have sex baby comes out and just
like whatever have you know what
whatever the combination of these two
people and we almost think of it like
eye color or hair color or whatever it
is like
let's see
yeah
but if you gave parents the ability to
choose
i don't know how many people would say
they'd do it but i gotta think it's a
pretty high percentage of people would
say hey i do want to pick the baby's eye
color i do want to pick the baby's you
know hair i do want to pick uh if you
give me
four embryos and by the way we're gonna
pick one of the four anyways
right exactly
then don't i want to have some data to
pick a
embryos that
i can optimize for whatever maybe it's
not intelligence i want to optimize for
maybe it's literally hey there's three
that have a high probability of brown
hair and one that has blonde hair and i
want a blonde haired baby
like or the data ends up being pretty
important or like it's not even that
like um the thing these companies start
off with um and they they like to talk
about like oh this is the only thing
you're ever going to do right we're
never going to talk about intelligence
um
the thing they start off with is just
health so you look at the diabetes risk
of these babies you look at the heart
disease risk you look at the cancer risk
you're like okay well i want my kid to
be healthy i'll pick the one that has
the least risk of having these things
that's where you start you can't draw a
line there right like
you could pick any of these embryos i
just want to pick the one that's going
to be make sure that my baby is healthy
as possible you go down the road right
like health correlates with intelligence
okay so why why don't we just start
testing for intelligence why don't we
start testing you can just go down this
road right there's also other kinds of
interesting technologies like just
cloning like we can clone a [ __ ]
horse now right we could we could clone
a human we could do it now and we have
you think so yes
just like nobody gives a [ __ ] enough
didn't some
no this was the china they did the
crisper thing wait you gotta back up a
second people can clone a full-blown
horse yeah how does that work
oh i mean
uh like i take like a 3d image of the
horse and then i like 3d print the horse
like how does this work
i don't remember these details but it it
it's like you it still has a gestate in
like okay so you basically somehow take
the dna the dna makeup of the horse it
still goes through kind of a birthing
process or whatever and then it becomes
essentially the same exact course so
this is more of genetic uh
um kind of science than it is uh some
sort of like oh no it's not like star
trek
yeah i was like all right i have not
seen that
i gotta do some more research um all
right and so your whole idea uh is like
we could do the same exact thing because
it's just genetics we could do it for
humans yeah no this guy wrote a really
interesting blog post about um
you know john neumann was this like
brilliant scientist in the 20th century
the literal probably the most brilliant
people who's a person who's ever lived
that we know of right so he's probably
in that iq of 180 he like
um there's so many like stories of him
uh
just uh
like he'll come these people are working
on problem for a week oh no there's a
great example of this where
he shows up late to a lecture
and
a professor is like writing down a
theorem on the board and he doesn't
realize that he's writing
he missed the introduction where the
professor was explaining that like he's
trying to prove the serum or explain it
so von neumann just like did he just
like fills in the rest of the steps of
the thing that the professor hadn't
proved yet he just like proves the
theorem that the professor was trying to
explain the introduction to um but no
the the that he's he worked on so many
like nuclear ballistics he worked like
he developed so many advances in like
computer hardware in quantum mechanics
quantum uh like
all kinds of things right this guy was
like the most brilliant person i've ever
lived
his body is in a cemetery in princeton
you dig that up you take a little sample
you have this dna you do get it
sequenced then you clone him maybe a
couple million times why don't we do
that
that's what i'm saying
but like like do you know what the
argument against it is probably illegal
in the us at least yeah but but like
what why i i actually heard the story
about like this guy who's he's like a
math project uh progeny and he was like
just emailing every single scientist uh
like he knew about like uh he was like
we know where the body is why don't we
just go dig it up and like clone them
and um um uh yeah so people have this
idea i i i don't like it it's just like
is it just
but so this is like a weird thing right
like there's there are uh what i would
consider morals right do not steal do
not cheat do not like these things that
uh i think
most humans through most of history have
bought into and said like yes for
whatever reason whether you agree or not
we've collectively agreed that like
these are bad things to do and uh those
morals i think are important because
they keep the fabric of society together
they uh give people a framework on how
to act and you know obviously i don't
think anyone really wants to live in a
society where it's like uh
uh the purge like just like go crazy
steal things kill people like you know
every person for themselves like that
doesn't seem uh to be super attractive
to folks
but then there's this like element of uh
ethics
which like
i'm not clear as to why it is a bad idea
to go find the smartest [ __ ] person
that's ever lived in the world
and take their dna and try to recreate
that over and over and over again so
that we can solve some of our hardest
problems these people matter a lot right
like we cloned elon musk
the thing with him having kids is
there's a lot of regression to the mean
so his kids are probably not going to be
as good as he was just because just the
same way it's like einstein's because
we're not as good as he was just like
it's very hard to keep that track but if
it's an exact clone of you
and then it's a different story right
you're thinking about how much value
elon musk has created for the world make
a bunch of copies of him
you know like we could have so much more
uh yeah so i think um
or are people just scared like does that
just scare the [ __ ] out of people and so
naturally it's like oh we can't do that
that's bad like it violates our ethics
like
if that's illegal right but then in 100
years people be like
look how stupid these humans were who
created laws it was illegal to do this
yeah like if you go back and you look at
laws that were written 100 years ago uh
many times they've now been repealed or
changed or whatever we laugh at them
yeah right we're like that was illegal
like that's what we all do today yeah i
think uh and the thing is that even if
we ban it
like china's gonna do it somebody else
is gonna do it china don't give a [ __ ]
they gotta go find they're gonna go find
the absolute smartest people they can
they don't care if they're chinese or
any other nationality or uh ethnicity
and they are going to do everything they
possibly can to get geniuses yeah and
that's a huge advantage like if you
think about who really like military
tech for example or like just advances
in physics hardware whatever you need
the smartest people right and there's
not that many of them around like this
you have a huge advantage does this also
play out not just with intelligence but
like for example uh is the chinese
military gonna create like herculean uh
looking cyborgs that all of a sudden
we're like damn
are humans aren't made like that and
it's because they are using some sort of
uh technology that maybe from an ethical
standpoint the u.s whether rightfully or
wrongfully uh has decided we're not
willing to use and they are yeah i think
we're gonna see some really wild [ __ ] in
the near future like i think there's two
paths of the future um one is you have
this human enhancement path and so then
the most powerful people in the world
are these like enhanced like just crazy
um crazy alterations of these people and
these people are like way smarter way
more capable
and the other path is you just go
completely artificial you have an
artificial general intelligence um one
of these two things i think is likely to
happen by the end of century and when
you take that seriously i mean there's
all sorts of other interesting trends
that i think will happen in the century
i think we might have energy super
abundance energy is like super [ __ ]
cheap um you can just travel from any
point in the world to any other point in
like a matter of minutes
um why is it going to get so cheap um so
like solar and wind are getting like if
you've seen the curves of the price on
those they just like drop exponentially
um there's the prospect that nuclear
could be much better if you know about
like the regulations um you know that
it's been hamstrung for decades if you
get rid of that you know like nuclear
could be way cheaper and way better
that's another like uh
fake ethical thing it seems like the
thing with the epic stuff is you have
during covid you had these bioethicists
who we're gonna do uh people had to say
you could do human challenge trials
whereas you give somebody the vaccine we
have the vaccine before the virus even
entered america they had designed the
vaccine so
um so but it took till november december
we had to fast track it and it still
took us a year to approve the vaccine
right so these people have the idea okay
the way the current process works is you
get to make the vaccine
if they happen to encounter covet and
they averted then you know that the
thing works right
the idea was you uh you give these
people the vaccine as early as possible
then you inject them with covid and if
they're able to avoid covet or don't
have the symptoms you know the vaccine
works these people volunteer to do this
they're getting paid to do it it's all
you know it's all full
disclosure and transparency it would
have sped up the vaccine by
many months would have saved more than
300 000 lives um
yeah so yeah
we were planning on this is something we
could have done but then the
bioethicists were like no this is
unethical and i'm an expert on ethics so
i can tell you that this is what does
that mean
exactly right
i get like you're an expert in like the
the proteins that make up the vaccine
again you could be like an actual expert
in biology
what is what does it mean to be an
expert in ethics i would argue you can't
even be an expert in biology you can be
one of the best first people on what we
currently understand about biology but
like we sure as hell understand less
than the things that we don't understand
right right and so like sure we'll call
that expertise for now but on ethics uh
it just feels like it it just made up
i want to stop shy of saying it's made
up because there are like morals again
right like there's things that i think
as a society we all agree like do not
cheat do not steal all that
but ethics has become this like
catch-all for just like anything that we
think we could complain about goes in
like the ethics bucket and so for
example if you have consenting adults
who say
hey
i'm willing to do this i understand the
risks and i'm signing whatever i'm a
young healthy person you know yaya or
whatever and somebody comes in and says
that's unethical like [ __ ] you right why
do you get to tell somebody what they
can do with their body
yeah now it all of a sudden it starts
entering into like the whole
conversation around like wait a minute
shouldn't you be able to do
whatever you want to do and this gets
out like well you can't go shoot up
heroin
well people still [ __ ] do it and i
don't see anyone being like yo that's
unethical right like i'm a bioethicist
that you shouldn't be allowed to do that
no they make a legal argument and so it
it's this very weird thing where
i think our uh
we've tricked ourselves as a society
specifically in america that there are
certain things in science math and
technology that are
off limits
which means that we are not doing
science
if things are off limits from an
experimentation standpoint again there's
the right way to do it there there's
opting in there's consent there's all
this stuff
but if people are willing to do it
and we say you're not allowed to do that
or we say um uh that is unethical
what's the difference between science
and religion this episode is brought to
you by eight sleep good sleep is a game
changer and the eight sleep pod is the
best sleep machine i sleep on it every
single night a great night of sleep
allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod three you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself and eat sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pomp today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
aidsleep.com not only do i sleep on it
every night it literally changed my life
and i begged the founders to let me
invest in the company
eightsleep.com go get yourself an
eight-sleep pod and get a better night
of sleep yeah and i think a lot of this
ethic stuff is just that you know people
have different intuitions i get that
right like some people they personally
wouldn't want like to do go through this
experiment that's totally fine um people
have like intuitions about
i know technology whatever right and so
they're like i don't like that but if
you say i don't like that you can't get
people you can't get like power to take
your side you can't get the government
to take your side but if you make the
argument no no this is unethical right
then that's like a political formula
that's a thing that you can go to the
government and say it's unethical
therefore we should regulate it um an
expert in ethics by the way makes me
think of like somebody saying uh i'm an
expert in opinions
like what does that mean yeah yeah uh
and then it also i think a step further
is like as a society we need certain
people to do [ __ ] that everyone doesn't
want to do yeah like the reason why we
have a safe country for the most part is
because there are bad ass men who are
willing to go in the dark of night and
kill people in other words right
guess what nobody likes talking about it
but i don't want to go do that [ __ ] you
don't want to go do that [ __ ] and 99.9
of americans don't want to do that [ __ ]
right but we got some bad [ __ ]
that'll go do it for us yeah and guess
what we celebrate them
we do it in this weird way where it's
like oh you're you're a navy seal that
sounds courageous
but like when you really look at like
what they're doing on a day-to-day basis
it's nasty [ __ ] yeah yeah
there it has to be in a bunch of other
fields like what's the equivalent of the
group of people who are willing to
dedicate their lives to do certain
things for some higher cause
that the average citizen doesn't want to
do but they're willing to do it yeah i
think just the entire world is made up
of these kinds of people i mean
i don't know it feels
it feels squirrely to like be be a
programmer or like be a content creator
or something and you realize that the
building you're sitting in was made by
people working at way lower wages than
you're doing much harder work than you
right it's like often these are like
illegal immigrants or people who don't
even have like
um who don't even have basic legal
protections and stuff um that's who is
basically build a civilization around
you just think like the guy who collects
your garbage the guy who's making sure
power is running to your house so much
of the civil civilization is just like
this api this interface you're
connecting to and it required so much
hard work um
it's like astounding when you think like
everything you like think about a
package you have and you're like trying
to get it to the other side of the
country just like traveling the other
side of country you can't connect any
corporations you can't connect training
government uh utility or anything you
just had to do it yourself it would take
you months years you would die on the
way right the the yeah i think people
used to do it right exactly i take the
horse and carriage right like we're
going west
and it literally took months and they
had a very high probability of dying
right exactly now obviously with certain
uh advancements in technology you're
unlikely to die but it sure would still
take a long time to do it even with a
car yeah yeah yeah and i think we also
underestimate how much like
when we think about history we often
think in terms of these activist
movements or we think in terms of these
political changes that have um improved
lives and so the vision of history we
have is very much like um 1776 1865 um
1965 you know like with this political
movement this activist move but i think
the real history of uh the real
uh understanding of history would also
include maybe it would be more important
to include just like technological
changes if you think about
um we had the green revolution in the
20th century if you uh norman borla was
a guy who created a variety of wheat
that was more resistant to
it was like more productive many times
more productive than the one before and
basically that was the thing that
prevented like hundreds of millions of
people potentially from dying in india
countries like that it's it said that he
probably saved a billion lives wow or
think about the
uh the haber bosch process for nitrogen
fixation which is used to make
fertilizer um
without the fertilizer that has nitrogen
like crops could not grow to anywhere
near the capacity they grow and how they
would be
land would not be as productive
agriculturally speaking at all there's
an estimate that they allowed 3.2
billion people to live that would not
otherwise exist so billions of people
just like these technologies you talk
about um
we don't include nobody knows about
these in people's names right they're
probably the greatest people who ever
lived in terms of if you think about
their impact um and they're not included
under history there's one person
one person a thousand years that will be
known that lives today uh satoshi no
okay elon musk ah and it's not a
guarantee yet yeah
he has to get us to mars yeah if he
figures out mars
he lives forever in the in the minds of
a kid born a thousand years from now do
you think you think i'll be able to get
there by 2030
the timeline's really hard i think that
uh i think spacex will
get a
vehicle or something to mars um
i question
will we get a human
on to
the surface of mars
i don't know the next 20 or 30 years
that one's like a tough one now they
believe it's gonna be
in the next eight years which like would
be [ __ ] like actually the eight year
part of that prediction is crazier to me
than like get to mars because it feels
like getting to mars is the foregone
conclusion at this point yeah it's the
time frame that would be mind-blowing
i'm not even sure it's a foreground
conclusion like we could have you don't
think we'll get to mars or i don't know
if it's like
if not for elon musk i think it could
like could have taken decades more
potentially never happened because i
don't i don't think unless somebody else
like him came along i don't think it was
ever even the people
the thing he did was he allowed people
to even imagine possible yeah right
and
there's still a lot of people who are
like why do you think it's possible
because this dude said it right like
like i don't know he seems to be the
expert right and so like if he says it's
possible that it must be possible and it
kind of goes back to like um uh venture
capital due diligence like like there's
some people who do the due diligence and
there's other people who say like who's
investing oh uh you know ex firm all
right cool they must have done the due
diligence right the problem here is that
like i don't have the uh the scientific
expertise or knowledge to actually
underwrite is it possible or is it not
so like to some degree expertise uh is
important because we can look to folks
right like imagine if every single one
of us had to go uh and learn about a
virus a vaccine like all this stuff and
then come to a conclusion as to like
what we should do and then we all took
like a democratic vote like that sounds
like a nightmare
by the way that's what dolls are
uh but if you think about um kind of
like mars it's like
yeah i do think that we will get there i
just eight years is you know seven and a
half years right seems
impossible right like it really does
like it is hard to think that way uh but
i guess if you look back i mean how many
flights
or how many launches per year was spacex
doing seven and a half years ago one
maybe i don't know the numbers right but
like they weren't doing one like every
three days or whatever they're doing you
know like
the rate of progress there is so
incredible that like sure maybe yeah
yeah no it's crazy
he's an excellent example of one
person's vision can
have a huge counter factual impact i
think after he uh founded paypal there
was like he immediately it wasn't like
he was gonna like take a recipe or
anything he immediately started working
on like tesla he had like plans for that
immediately um i think like yeah it is
astounding when you have a person who's
like able to actually make their but
think back a thousand years
we couldn't name anyone
we don't [ __ ] know anybody
right like literally no one
yeah and guess what they thought they
were important they thought their you
know contributions to society were
essential they're somebody who thought
they were the the leader of you know the
free world or whatever nobody remembers
their names
we over the history of
earth
i don't know
500 people
maybe that we can think of that we're
like
okay these people are really important
but the further you get away from their
inventions
the less important they become yeah i
think it's also another example of the
power law you're talking about the
venture where if you think about impact
on literature and who you remember
shakespeare is like way up here he's
like he's like the test love literature
and then the next person is like
probably less than half as important as
him in terms of literature and then you
have just this long tail of people who
are like i'm gonna be a great author and
nobody will ever remember your name yeah
yeah um or true philosophers true of
like leaders world leaders the person
who matters the most is going to matter
so much more than everybody else
combined
also uh if things continue the way that
they are going uh
uh when we talk about human enhancement
um i was thinking to myself if you
walked out on the street in middle
america anywhere kind of outside of a
tech industry uh kind of uh hub and you
said uh there's this thing called human
enhancement we have uh option a and
option b option a is we can make you
super intelligent or option b is we can
make you ripped with a six pack and like
huge biceps yeah
what percentage of people would pick
super intelligence and what percentage
would pick like visual enhancement what
do you what do you think because i have
a i have a friend we debate this all the
time and he thinks cause i'm like okay
everybody's gonna be super intelligent
because like all the parents are gonna
be like i want my kids no they want a
six-pack
they want to go they want to go hook up
with people like that's what they want
they want the six-pack like that's the
problem
is that like that is human nature right
he's not like let me be super
intelligent and like change the
trajectory of my family and like
no they're like cool if i have a
six-pack and i go to the beach like
maybe i can find somebody that like will
want to sleep with me yeah but the crazy
like um
this is like a i don't know almost uh
thing you don't want to admit the thing
is intelligence is actually correlated
with a lot of things like intelligence
and good looks are correlated we'll
explain that more which is um if you
think about the most intelligent people
are usually better looking than people
like on average right and the reason is
one of the reasons i mean there's
mutational load and there's other kinds
of things one of the funny reasons is
the most beautiful woman
mate with the most intelligent men or
just like people who are very competent
in getting something done they were
successful successful people on average
are more intelligent they get the most
beautiful woman you know what i mean
like that kind of the so you're going to
see i think um and also the most
intelligent woman also made with the
most noted there's like nutrition yeah
exactly and that's why isn't nature
already doing what we were talking about
earlier in terms of picking the embryos
like the advantageous embryos yeah yeah
or i mean there's a disgenic effect
because they're not having as many kids
so in the sense nature is not picking
nature is segregating them but nature is
actually preferring the um
like on average this is like you know
basic common sense we know that smart
people have fewer babies than uh like
college graduates have fewer babies than
uh you know high school dropouts or
something why do you think that is like
what's driving that's that's really
that's i think an interesting question
because you see a broader um
you see this throughout not just our
society but throughout the world like
the societies that are poorer have more
kids as societies get wealthier their
fertility like drops off a cliff i i
don't think we have a good answer to
that and i think over the long term it
is gonna have a big unless we get
obviously if we already have agi who
cares about the average intelligence
right or if we have human enhancement
the dysgenic effect is not going to be
that important but if that doesn't
happen um i think the dysgenic effect is
going to be like by the end of the
century we'll be like two or three a
little over three iq points dumber on
average than we are now which doesn't
sound like a lot because the average 100
but a small difference at the mean has a
huge impact on the tails the number of
people who have like an iq above 130
will get like cut by more than half
especially when the population itself is
declining right so yeah i think that's
uh that's the thing to think about
when we get these like brain computer
interfaces going into this like human uh
enhancement and intelligence uh
should we be worried
that people who opt out for either
ethical reasons or just like they're
uncomfortable like will they just get
left in the dust yeah yeah or like like
what like how does this work or do we
get to a point where they're like yo
everyone has to do this
we'll just make like separate
reservations for them they can like live
as live as
noble savages it's a very crazy thing to
think about where if uh
let's say it was a cost thing right
should the government say if you don't
have the money to enhance your
intelligence then like we're going to
help you do that like
that's going to become a conversation
100 percent
uh at the same time do the people who
aren't
opting in with their own money like
you're not putting that chip in my brain
and like i don't want to participate
because my government's telling me to do
it yeah i i think i think uh
it'll be interesting there obviously
will be a lot of people who reject
working with that kind of stuff i think
probably the reality is that they're not
going to be that economically or
politically important
the the opposite hypothesis is that oh
they're going to be like um they're
going to be a minority of economic value
like most they can market value is going
to generate people who have been
enhanced but they're going to still have
if it's still democracy then they're
still going to have a lot of political
power with their political power they
can just like i don't know make it
illegal or something but the difficulty
is like how do you make it illegal
somebody can just get a visa to go to
panama or you know singapore is like
some country which allows it you go do
medical tourism you're actually making
it more difficult
for
that means that the elite people can
still do it right they can just take a
trip uh but the middle class people who
could have actually done it they might
not be able to
um so
if you just like add regulations you
might actually be making inequality
worse i think at root distribution
genetic root distribution in terms of
just giving you these services i think
it's probably going to be have you heard
this is going to be a crazy uh thing
that i don't know why i know this uh
have you heard of the uh brazilian butt
lift you know what this is
well is it like the thing that kim
kardashian has i'm sure she has it right
but basically it's a surgical procedure
which i'm not an expert on unfortunately
uh but they basically enhance your butt
by doing some sort of like butt lift and
i i believe that it is uh they put um uh
somewhere like a breast implant or
something right but in the butt the
reason why
i know what a brazilian butt lift is is
because one day i was doomed scrolling
on twitter wasting time and i saw a
photo and it was in the atlanta airport
and somebody had taken a photo and ben
and said something to the effect of like
uh man these bbls are really out of
control
and i was like what the hell's a bbl
right like and it was literally the in
the photo was just a line of wheelchairs
of all like
women maybe between the ages of
you know again i'm guessing from the
photo but like maybe like 25 and like
40.
and i was like
what's going on in atlanta right like
what's up bbl google whatever uh
probably got targeted with a million ads
like some dude googling bbl and uh
one of the things was that there's been
an explosion of uh
medical tourism i'll put under the
category of people leaving the united
states going to i forget one of the
countries in latin america to get these
done and then they come back but once
you get it done you can't walk very well
so they need the
in the beginning right after medical
procedure right
um
and so
what the photo was was a bunch of people
coming back who were now in a long line
of wheelchairs because they all had gone
in like from this country and gotten
these bbls
and so i just remember sitting myself
thinking like holy [ __ ] like this human
enhancement stuff is already here to
some degree we think of it as cosmetic
right whether people agree with it don't
agree with it whatever it's obviously
happening uh
but like that's what people are
interested in yeah and so like what's
the difference between a bbl where you
have to fly to the country to go get it
done to
hey i want to go get a brain computer
interface yeah i i wonder how common
those are because i i don't know just
walking around miami i might have seen a
few of them
with that or the girls were just gifted
but it go it goes back to uh
society evolves there's change that
happens um and what is aspirational or
what is uh kind of celebrated
is emulated through a society right this
has been true of human nature for
thousands of thousands of years uh
but
that's usually physical
so what clothes you wear how you look
right actions you do like all that stuff
intelligence is this weird thing
it's invisible
yeah you know it when you interact with
it and you
have heard rumors or somebody can tell
you oh that person is very smart or
you assume because somebody accomplished
something that they are intelligent
but you can't actually feel it you can't
see it you can't you know whatever
i think that that's a huge issue as to
why when it comes to human enhancement
people won't opt for that
you can't flex your intelligence
on instagram yep i think you're right no
i think intelligence is
one of the things where we have a
difficulty talking about it because we
don't want to admit that it's a big part
of it's inherited
um and then there's actual different
genetic differences between individuals
whereas you know people know that people
look different right like there's
differences in height there's
differences even in health uh
genetically but i i think we're going to
face the biological reality of
intelligence when
modifying it biologically is going to be
possible
it well it already is possible to some
degree right and one of the fascinating
debates right now is around uh like
ritalin or like adhd like all this stuff
and it's well documented that like i
when i was in school adhd was not like a
popular thing now it's like every kid
has adhd let's drug them all up
everybody both has adhd apparently
every adult apparently has adhd too yeah
and so like
why is it okay for us to like stuff
pills down kids throats right and like
get them drugged up versus hey let's put
a computer to make you more intelligent
like it feels both are going in your
body yeah sure when you digest one is
more like a surgical procedure so like
there's a severity uh difference
but it sure seems like it's probably
safer
uh in the end state to do the surgery
than to keep like putting pills in our
children and drugging them up yeah
especially because those are just
transient benefits right like you get
over the drug you might even be worse
off because you've built up tolerance or
something
and i don't think um
there is difficult i don't think a drug
will ever be able to like make you
smarter maybe just like those just sort
of stimulants that help you focus right
but to make your smarter yet actually
change the architecture of the brain and
that's not going to be an easy thing to
do
after your brain has already developed i
don't know how neuralink stuff will
develop but yeah um whereas i think yeah
i think uh
your brain on adderall and your brain on
envious elections
there's gonna be a big difference yeah
um you wrote a piece about the myth of
the myth of a well-read person
what is this yeah so
people have this idea
that
people don't realize that you can
actually know everything okay and i so i
have a podcast and i get a chance to
talk to these people who have
comprehensive knowledge about everything
that matters everything you can know um
like tyler cow and bernhard are these
kinds of people
and there's nothing you could say to
them that they haven't already
considered there's no objection that
they haven't already looked at no
implication that they haven't already um
analyzed and the thing is these people
are just relentless infovores
and if you think about the kind the
amount of knowledge you need to
understand a subject right so take
economics for example
let's say you've read a dozen books
about economics not just random books
but like books that give you a broad
explanatory understanding of what's
happening then you do that for biology
then you do that for computer science
how long does it take you to read 12
books if you get a serious effort at it
right you can do this for multiple
disciplines in a single year now do this
for the rest of your life
if you read the right book every once
every week or something for the rest of
your life
you could know 80 about every single
field in the world right and people have
this idea that oh knowledge is so
specialized
the you can't like you know there's like
new books every single day that you
can't possibly ingest all the
information
if by information you just mean like
you're memorizing trivial details like
you're memorizing the gdp or different
asian countries like how many ant
species there are yeah sure you can
memorize all the information but just
these basic explanatory frameworks
they don't change that often in fact
they if you think there's been a
relative stagnation economically and in
terms of knowledge recently they
actually are turning over very
infrequently like
quantum mechanics right like you talk
about quantum mechanics we're like oh
that's super woo that's like a new thing
in physics it's a hundred years old
right you
these things don't change that much or
like neo-darvenian synthesis 50 years
old fear of computation almost 100 years
old
so you can learn about these fundamental
ideas
and people don't seem to take this
prospect seriously because how many
people do you know who are actually
making an effort to know everything i
think it's a thing you can do and i
think there are people who are
attempting it why is it important to
know everything
i think the returns to knowing more
things have increased over time so if
you think about like a farmer in the
17th century right even if he knew
everything about everything all the
knowledge i was able to time what he's
gonna do with it right like he's not
um he only needs to know knowledge about
the thing he's particularly working on
like a book on guano farming or
tree cutting or something
whereas today
if you understand for example
how um economic growth works how finance
works and you also understand let's say
how
nuclear fusion works and you also
understand computer science you can put
marriage the software and the hardware
parts you can like build a multi-billion
dollar business right or you can become
like you are a content creator who's
able to synthesize all this information
and put it together and you can have
like a huge brand that way so the
returns to knowing about a lot of things
in a d fundamental way have increased a
lot over time like i think today that
you think elon musk is a great example
of this this guy knows a [ __ ] ton about
their stories about he would like show
up to parties after the paypal days um
and then he would just like be reading
of like a russian uh russian textbook by
rocketry or something
that that kind of him just having a
obsession with learning about different
uh fields reading textbooks on that
papers on that that was the look at the
returns he's had on that right yeah it
also reminds me of this idea uh
generalist versus specialist and
obviously specialists are very important
in certain fields you know uh you want
your doctor to be a specialist you want
your uh lawyer probably to be a
specialist um and many other you know
types of fields uh but the generalist i
think society uh based on books and
articles and even twitter and the way
the conversation plays out generalist
means knowing a little bit about a whole
bunch of things but really what it
sounds like you're making an argument
for is knowing uh a good amount about
the right things
there's a difference there it's not just
hey do i i've heard of quantum mechanics
right and i know what field it is and
and maybe i read you know a one
paragraph description one time but if
that is one of the 50 things that matter
uh and are the right things to know
about then can i know 80 or can i know
50 about that field uh that's very
different than like an inch deep and a
mile wide yeah i know i think that
that's a great point you make because a
big failure mode you can have is
people when people say generalist they
say i'm a generalist right often what
they mean is like
i
yeah i don't have a specialty any like i
don't know that much about any
particular thing but like i don't know
i've like looked into certain things um
and i think this is a big problem with
uh
not a huge problem but i think this is
something to think about when you're
reading these pop side books often they
don't give you that deep understanding
of the subject they're talking about
there's really some good really good
exceptions to this but yeah if you take
a serious effort to like actually
understanding things which is very
different from how do you do it like you
said the myth of the myth of a well-read
person is it just reading
no well it really helps out a podcast
because i can't just
passively ingest information i have to
really think about what the point the
person is making what implications their
argument has what contradictions it has
um and that i think uh that really helps
me make sure that i'm really
understanding things in a defendant
mental way i really think that the thing
i'm trying to do with the podcast i've
had it for um i've been working on a
full time for not that long
uh i'm trying to develop a world view
and by world view i don't mean like a
political worldview like you know who
should we vote for in the next election
but just in terms of like where we are
in history what is going to matter in
this century what is going to matter in
the long term um like how do it sounds
vague and ambiguous when you describe it
generically but it requires you to
understand a lot of fields deeply which
i don't yet but i'm trying to um you
can't make an assessment on the broader
question of where we are in history but
unless you understand where ai is going
where nuclear is going where human
enhancement is going where the economy
is going what the rate of economic
growth is going to be over time we're
society how society and culture are
going to change over time you need to
understand all these fields and i think
there's various people in the world and
i'm by no means one of these people i
think there's very people in the world
who've actually developed a
comprehensive worldview
and i think
but when they do it it's really
remarkable and those people are really
valuable so let's just go through this
because this is a fascinating exercise
uh develop a view is a very intentional
action i'm gonna go develop worldview
why is that important is it just it
makes you a better thinker it allows you
to pick a uh occupation to go after like
what is the importance of selecting that
as okay this is an activity worth
pursuing yeah
well usually when something is really
rare um it often ends up being valuable
there's if you look at the
specialization in academia and other
parts of the world there's very people
whose job it is
to just think about the whole picture
um and so it is a rare thing to do and
you ask like okay well why is it
valuable just because it's rare doesn't
necessarily make it valuable that's a
fair point uh but if you look at some of
the most successful people in the world
like think of peter tulo right they say
that his um hedge fund is basically like
a think tank rolled up in a venture
capital firm rolled up in a hedge fund
but it starts off you look at what he
spends his days doing there's you know
he's like having seminars on strauss or
hegel or something it starts off with
these like very fundamental first
principles thinking about like where
different sectors are headed i think if
you want to find the most important
things to work on which is probably what
you should be doing with your career
you it would be very strange you just
accidentally happen to work on them to
work on them you need to have you
actually need a worldview that first
actually points out to you what the most
important things to work on are right um
i guess that you don't need to like
obviously it's more to like actually
start working on the thing itself as
well right and that's also part of how
you develop that worldview
but yeah to actually focus on the most
important things you need a worldview
and that doesn't necessarily i'm not
just talking about like philosophy or
humanity stuff it also requires like
technical expertise in a lot of fields
okay so you say i want to go develop a
world view how do you then choose what
are the things that are important within
that there's a million topics you could
go to uh the new york public library and
walk around and there's section after
section after section how do you know
which ones are worth spending time on
and which ones do you pass on right and
i think that actually is part of the
world view is well one of the things
worldview tells you is what is the most
important thing what are the most
important things to be focusing on
um
i think you can it's very easy to see
when something is not going to be the
most important thing like i think it's
important to take a barbell view of how
to think about the the most important
things they're not if you look at the
news right it's things that are
transient and trivial people say the
news is too pessimistic or is too
optimistic it's neither optimistic or
pessimistic enough it doesn't focus
enough on the upside the things that are
really going to revolutionize the world
you know new technologies
um
you know like let's say making steel
gets much cheaper what kinds of new
things can you construct let's say
batteries get much better what kinds of
new uh what kinds of new uh robots and
stuff uh you know cars things can be
built it also doesn't focus enough on
the downsides you know like what happens
if there's a
man-made pandemic a lab leak a new lap
leak um
that kills billions of people right uh
what happens if the person who develops
ai somebody like china where their uh
their
norms and values are not gonna be
aligned with ours so you you
it's not going to be the thing that most
people are thinking about because the
thing that most people are thinking
about is usually something that people
have already looked into and also it's
likely to not be like you're just
thinking about like what do people talk
about day to day it's going to be the
things that nobody's talking about and
but that requires you to yeah it's i
think it's a good question i honestly
don't have a good answer like where do
you start except just
like look at everything and try to
understand in a fundamental way
and then once you get into one of the
topics let's just use quantum mechanics
as uh an example so hey i believe that
this is an important field uh to
understand better what does that process
look like to go from i know nothing to
i've got 25 50 80
understanding of this field yeah i um
i actually we're learning about quantum
computing was a thing that really made
me decide that i wanted to do something
more interesting with my career because
yeah i was taking scott anderson is like
probably the greatest living theoretical
computer scientist in the world and i
was taking his class on quantum
computing and you know you you you think
about how quantum computing works if you
take the multi-diversity of quantum
mechanics it's literally different
branches of the universe colliding to
form an answer to a computer science
problem you have um it's such an
interesting problem and
it's so much more interesting than like
i don't know like building a database
for google or something so
but yeah so how would you learn about
that i think um it's important to not
get lost in the details but also to make
sure that you're understanding
i i think usually the best textbook on
the subject are actually pretty good at
helping you understand things um
generally it's you you should do the
exercises you need to
um
you yeah you can uh you don't need to
memorize trivial details but you should
also understand the actual fundamentals
in a deep way
yeah and then when you start to look at
the i'll call it like base knowledge
it's almost like you're going to the
source materials whether it's the
textbook or whatever to learn about the
the information uh you develop this
world view are there folks that you
think have developed those world views
that you're like okay you mentioned
peter thiel are there others that you
say hey these folks seem to have figured
it out yeah i think somebody like uh
bern hobart tyler cowan
there's a few people like this and
things there's not that many of them
but you can you ingest there from will
mccaskill um these people have different
royalties right and that's what makes
them interesting it'd be really strange
if you just happen to land upon the same
worldview if you're both thinking from
different premises
they have different worldviews but the
implication of these world views means
that once they come out of that uh
exercise of thinking about different
problems
um
then they come up with these really
interesting problems to work on uh those
are some great examples uh but like for
example one week high school is this
philosopher who has this new book on
long-term and somehow to improve the
future and so he just starts from the
first premise of well
let's make sure the future goes well
okay what are the things that could
matter for making sure the future goes
well well one thing is if society
collapses we want to make sure that we
can restart society okay well how do we
do that well we would need another
initial revolution if the society
collapses what do we need for industrial
revolution well we would need coal right
because coal is the easiest thing to
find and burn photovoltaics and solar
and stuff they just degrade really fast
nuclear will degrade over time so you
just need to like take off some coal and
start burning up the furnaces again okay
so maybe we should um just conserve some
easy to access ground coal
um that's close to the ground
okay so just starting from first
principle as you come to the conclusion
that we need to set up some sanctuaries
of coal right that's just one example of
the strange implications that come from
thinking for first principles austin
vernon comes from an engineering
background he has this blog that not
that many people know about
he comes to the conclusion he's looking
at the declining cost of energy over
time he says okay if energy keeps
declining over time at some point it
will become economical to take co2 in
the air in the atmosphere and use um
electrolyte lysis to uh convert that
into actual materials used to build
things or used as biofuels like ethanol
formic acid things like that okay once
that becomes economical people are gonna
start doing that a lot and once you
start doing that there's gonna be a
shortage of co2 in the air right okay so
he starts off this very basic first
principle thinking of what is the cost
of energy what are the trends in energy
cost okay maybe that means that there's
an energy there's a short uh co2
shortage in the air which is much more
dangerous than overproduction of co2 and
does he put a timeline on something like
that yeah well he it's not super precise
but he thinks by 2100 it'll be it will
be negative carbon in a way that's like
substantially a negative carbon i think
it's at 2070 actually which goes counter
to pretty much the
entire mainstream conversation at the
moment of uh we're gonna be in the
opposite situation you know i think
that's really strange uh really
interesting and um strange
if you look at some of the predictions
throughout history that people have had
often they've actually identified the
correct problem they get the
direction of the factor
exactly opposite think of
population right so in the 70s there's
books about how the world population is
going gangbusters and you know there's
going to be overpopulation and if you
think of first principles it makes a lot
of sense right the people who have the
most babies are going to eventually make
up most of the population over time
that's going to drive selection towards
people who have more babies um and if
you love a lot of babies they're going
to be a malthusian thing where
there's not enough food to feed all the
people uh we'll hit the carrying
capacity of the earth and everybody over
that will die of famine plague war all
kinds of nasty [ __ ] so first principles
that makes a lot of sense um and they
were right that population is the thing
that's going to matter a lot but the
thing that actually looks like it's
going to be the trend is going to be
that we won't have enough population the
real popul the real problem for
civilization will be that there's not
enough people and it would be very
similar to the carbo i'm not saying this
is likely but if with the climate change
thing if it turned out the real problem
in 2100 is that there's not enough co2
in the atmosphere right we identify the
uh the correct um problem we're just
going to the order the um the direction
of it completely wrong and this is an
interesting trend
we didn't even identify the right
problem we identified the right topic
yeah right co2 yeah everyone thinks it's
one thing but they misjudge and ends up
being the opposite problem and you know
i've said this to you before but to me
it's uh you're on the highway and
sometimes there's an exit uh which it
looks like you're just kind of veering
off the highway it's not a very um uh uh
kind of high degree changing direction
right it's not a 90 degree hit the stop
sign go right it shows hey we're all
going together at 65 miles an hour
because we follow the speed limit and
then you know somebody in the far right
lane they just kind of peel off onto the
exit
some of those exits continue in the
similar direction for a little bit
but some exits
end up actually being 180 degrees and
you basically do a 180 right you just
come around and then you end up going in
the opposite direction
and that's what it feels like uh which
is when you're going down the highway of
these ideas you can actually end up in
the far right lane or you can end up in
the second to right lane and that
determines even though it doesn't look
like a huge uh kind of divergence at the
onset of the exit
one keeps going straight and one ends up
going in the other direction uh and so
to me there's a lot of these right where
we end up seeing it what i don't know is
how do we get people to understand maybe
your conclusion is wrong you have
identified the right topic to discuss
but your conclusion is wrong yeah it
should be clear by the way i think
i think this is just like a hypothetical
future the climate change thing i think
probably it's more likely there'll be an
over production of co2 than that do you
think so well yeah so why do you think
his analysis is wrong
uh he it requires energy to get
significantly cheaper than it is now and
i think that's possible but
i'm not sure uh that
let's say that that's at 50 right that
energy gets an order manager cheaper and
then you have the probability that okay
then people will really want to take
carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere to
do these things instead of like making
manufacturing these materials another
way that's another probability out of
that and you just like chain together
all the things that are true for his
vision to be true then you get to like
something under 50 right um was that the
same
analysis in hindsight of the 1970s
overpopulation like you had to believe
multiple things no i think you're right
but because
their analysis are the people who
thought overpopulation was going to be a
problem
their analysis was pretty
straightforward right it's just like
people have kids uh we
we have limited amounts of um food so
then there won't be enough food and land
for them and if you were the contrarian
in the 1970s would the analysis has
simply been
yes there are people having a lot of
babies today but as the entire society
becomes wealthier and there's like
economic mobility we know that there's
less kids
in those wealthier families and so
therefore population overall declines
and society
across the world but specifically in the
western world is naturally
mobile yeah upwards but
how would they have even known that at
the time because there were very few
wealthy societies in that i think
fertility in the us was probably
um i mean it was it was starting to
decline because of the sexual revolution
stuff but even even as recently as like
yeah the 50s obviously baby boomers and
stuff the first letter was surprising
how would you have possibly predicted
back then even today we don't understand
why fertility is declining right so how
could you have known before it happened
in the 50s that would have happened yeah
it would have been really tough and
that's another thing about that
predicting the future it's like really
hard to know what you know we talk about
like human assignment ai energy support
and things
i think the probably the most important
things are probably things we haven't
even realized are going to be really
important i think it's really hard to
predict the future
it's definitely it's nearly impossible
to predict the future um especially
across so many different dimensions
right so again it goes back to uh almost
being prepared right rather than a
prediction uh prediction
can you simply know a deep amount of
some good uh important things and then
you're best prepared to handle whatever
comes next although uh you cannot
predict it right yeah uh one of the
problems that uh i actually believe
has much more impact on society than uh
one people understand you know in terms
of severity problem but two is how
far-reaching the um problem uh or impact
is uh is the declining testosterone yeah
like
10 years ago no one was really talking
about it now i think there's like uh
kind of a subset of the population who
says hey you know like red flag like i
think there might be a problem here um
my guess is five ten years from now like
it'll be a pretty widely accepted like
why is this happening maybe we don't
understand it but like this is a problem
um but what's fascinating to me is if
you look on the uh kind of small scale
for one single person
the impact of low testosterone versus
high testosterone
is like completely different people
right in terms of energy uh productivity
sleep quality health i mean like there's
so far reaching
that it feels like if you then say okay
across society it's like we're gonna
essentially downgrade all of these
individuals in terms of performance
quality of life all this stuff due to
lower testosterone and then we're gonna
add them all together to make up society
yeah
pretty important issue that you know we
don't understand uh and we probably
underestimate
uh the impact like how much of uh
the
a perceived increase in violence that we
see
uh is due to
lower testosterone that leads to mental
health issues that then leads to
violence now again i'm not making the
case that that's what's happening yeah
but if that 20 years from now there was
an analysis and we could make those
connections we would all be left
scratching your head saying like holy
[ __ ] like no one saw that yeah and so
maybe it's not right but who knows i i
think you're uh
the um
if you think about the difference
between like a 20 year old guy and a 40
year old guy in terms of like their
worldviews what kinds of problems like
how how how much energy they have like
what kinds of risks they're willing to
take
if you think that happens over the sp
the entire society has turns from like
basically oh the difference between a 20
year old and a 40 year old in terms of
yes
like being more risk-averse uh be
one of the things testosterone does it
just makes effort fun yes right that's
why like 20 year olds will like work you
know 14 hours like you know in
programming it's like a common thing
right um just and then obviously like
it's less common to see that as people
get older
and also that's why
they're like these examples of like 20
year olds would like build these huge
obviously
the median startup founder is older but
a lot of these people who end up
becoming huge founders
i don't know maybe
uh
it's like maybe jeff facebook is
probably like i don't know on trt or
something um and facebook today's a
little different than jeff bezos 1999
yes
it's kind of insane he looks younger
than 20 years ago like i was not alive
when he looked older than he looks now
um but you know that i think
testosterone is really interesting
because
they've done these experiments on birds
there's i forgot the species but it's
like a monogamous bird species the males
of the species have high testosterone
um like just
naturally when they're single
when they made and they form a
monogamous pair and especially after
they have kids their testosterone just
goes down declines
um by like many factors uh and yeah so
part of that is like you don't want to
be this aggressive risk-taking person
after you've already had kids you want
to like make sure things are safe and
low volatility once you have kids
but the thing is there's more single men
now so you would think that testosterone
would increase as
people being single increases
um it's really mysterious i i don't know
if you have a good understanding of it
could be the um it could be like the
receipts and the chemicals and i said
that just this morning i was getting the
coffee and then it was like you got to
carry this receipt from here to here uh
they feel like make you take this what's
the argument for receipts i've heard
water bottles and things like that but
what is recycling i don't remember the
exact thing but like apparently the
receipts have some chemicals that uh
through your skin will have some adverse
impact on your testosterone uh so like
stop receipts is gonna become like a
social movement to like like get rid of
it yeah i i i feeling the environment
wasn't a big enough deal right it's like
to [ __ ] with our testosterone and when
receipts are gone yeah [ __ ] it we'll do
digital um
what do you think it is like why are
men's testosterone levels decreasing uh
i don't think it's one single factor
like these things are uh uh usually
based on historical uh examples like
multiple things that come together uh i
definitely believe it has something to
do with uh with water um both from like
the tap and also uh water bottles i mean
if you just look we have a bunch of
water bottles here um i mean
yeah yeah well if if you also think
about um
uh we're talking earlier today about uh
do you spend more time with your feet on
the ground in a standing and walking
position or do you spend more time with
your ass and a seat yeah right and and
what we're talking about was uh
should you spend more money on your
shoes or on the chair you sit in every
day right like in some ways like people
think of like oh i want to be
comfortable when i'm walking like
they're my everyday issues but like the
chair you sit in you actually may spend
more time there than with the shoes on
and so uh same thing goes for uh
consuming liquids do you consume more
liquids uh
in a water bottle or without a water
bottle right and i'm not talking like
you know people have like these like uh
uh titanium or whatever the thing i'm
talking about like actual plastic water
bottles like if you start to almost
audit your like
liquid intake my guess is people would
be shocked at the percentage of water
they drink that's out of a water bottle
versus something else yeah and so again
there's debatable is it actually water
bottles is it not whatever but like that
seems to be have some impact to it
the third thing is uh
shit's safe
like we live in the safest time in human
history right like you don't need to
uh
be worried for the most part right uh
that when you walk down the street
someone may try to kill you you're not
worried about a wild animal again for
the most part you know coming into where
you sleep and killing you at night
you're not worried about going out and
hunting for food um and so just
naturally i think humans evolve and so
like you get some drop that doesn't
explain the significant drop in the last
20 years uh but definitely the longer
term trend and then i think that there's
uh a social thing
and this is where people get real weird
and they don't like talking about it but
like
there is a very obvious at least to me
uh trend of uh masculinity
being
maybe not deterred
but definitely uh adding more friction
to encouraging that and so you can see
it in the type of content that is
created from you know hollywood and
things like that uh you can see it in um
uh
social media and kind of sentiment
changes uh but also
you can just see it in like what we ask
of people in society and some of this is
not like a man thing
if we are a society that says okay we
used to be
100 capitalism and now maybe we're like
wow capitalism is good but like now
there's some times where like socialism
is good right and we don't say it that
way but like that's what ends up
happening
what it does is it dulls right i think
doling is a is a good work you don't
take away certain aspects socially what
you're doing is you're dulling the
self-reliance the independence the like
uh kind of characteristics that
hit for thousands of years
masculinity was very similar to and so
when you start to look at it it's like
you can't point to any one thing and you
can't even point to one thing in the
last 20 years necessarily it's all of
this stuff coming together
and so if you said to yourself like
forget like maybe water and plastics and
things like that like what would have
the rate of decline been anyways
right and what how had it fallen from
you know i don't know a thousand a.d
right to like 1500. yeah yeah yeah no i
think um if you look at the history of
violence throughout history
where else would you look um
um
you see i think it's a good thing
that you see a huge decline in violence
over time even if you look at the time
that testosterone has been decreasing
let's say the last few decades look at
like crime rates in the 90s look at
crime rates now there's been a recent
resurgence but over time crime rates
have been like dropping a lot i think
that probably has to do with the fact
that there's low testosterone um just
read like or read the iliad or the
odyssey or something like people are
constantly getting butchered um and i
think that probably was not just the
story i mean this thing itself was a
story but i think that was an indication
of the kind of societies people lived in
in terms of the ever-present nature of
violence
um of genocide of war and so
you know maybe the way to think about
declining testosterone is just as like
declining volatility in the sense that
yes you'll have fewer criminals if
there's less testosterone um but you'll
also have fewer jeff faces than elon
musk's because one of the things that
drives them at least when they were
young and building up their career
capital building up their skills is i'm
guessing the average startup founder
probably has more testosterone than the
average person i was going to ask i
wonder if you could break down the
person who takes the job at google
versus the person who starts a company
right and you did an entire study uh the
expectation i think again you'd have to
run the experiment to know would be that
the startup founder would have higher
testosterone right than the person who
took the job at google and then i wonder
if there was even a difference between
the successful
founder and the not successful founder
yeah right now some of it's outside
their controllers market conditions
there's all this type of stuff
but if there was a difference it would
be interesting
and you can imagine the backlash to a
study that uh if it got to the
conclusion and linked higher
testosterone levels with higher success
there would be [ __ ] chaos right
people would be like oh that's [ __ ]
whatever because then all of a sudden
the question would become should
rather than sticking computers in
people's brains like it's the first step
uh hey don't drug people with ritalin
like instead just like hand out
testosterone to people right like like
all i'm saying is look at the amazon
stock price in the last five years
that's all i'm saying
um
but regarding the chemicals in the water
i there's um uh there's this blogger
slime multimode that have been
looking at the increase in obesity over
the last few decades and their theory
it's not just like people are eating
shittier food it's also that maybe
there's
chemicals in the water and they're
trying to figure out what it is
that are
um that are causing this increase in
obesity and other pieces of evidence is
if you look at
places that are higher in elevation like
places like colorado they have lower
obesity rates than places that are lower
in elevation and next to rivers so think
of like
louisiana or texas or something those
places have higher obesity rates so if
it's and if it's just like runoff of
chemicals that's exactly what you'd
expect but how much of it is just like
people in colorado like to go outside
and people in louisiana you know the
generalization would be like they go you
know to mardi gras and yeah [ __ ]
fried chicken no i think that's right
that's probably the good null hypothesis
like i think that's also good and uh
food is a fascinating thing so um
there's a small town in north carolina
uh that i drove through uh two years ago
or so and when we were driving through
uh polina said to me she goes
wow i was like what she's like look and
we were at a red light and we could see
kind of through the town and there was i
don't know maybe
three lights or so four lights right uh
and it's next to a highway so it's like
right off the exit of the highway
every
single place that you could get food
was completely unhealthy
mcdonald's wendy's you know all these
things and then it was like you know uh
cracker barrel right i mean like you
know every single thing and it was like
if you live in this town other than go
to the grocery store there's not a
single thing from what we could see that
was a healthy option yeah and so low
cost convenient and the abundance of
options right ends up leading people to
bad health and
diets
but also
when you layer in some of this other
stuff of sedentary lifestyle you know
whatever
and then you've got the genetics on top
of it like it just stacks on top and i
actually think for the average american
living in a small town the deck is
completely stacked against them doesn't
mean it is not possible to live a
healthy lifestyle to be in shape to do
all this stuff but like it sure as hell
ain't easy
and so
that then i think is also a contributor
like you have the stuff in the water but
like you sure aren't optimizing your
testosterone if you're eating mcdonald's
every day yeah right and so how much is
food how much is water how much is
social like there's a lot of stuff in
there that just ultimately leads to
man testosterone testosterone's going
down and like we probably should try to
figure it out yeah and i think probably
obesity is maybe the most important if
you think about what is the thing that's
the biggest factor to testosterone
declining
i wouldn't be shocked if it's just
obesity like people are fatter i think
fat
if i remember correctly becoming fatter
decreases your testosterone or increases
your estrogen or something like that uh
because yeah obviously like the fat
stores hormones um
but yeah i think this is uh not just
testosterone but this is like a broader
thing about society over time becoming
more complacent and part of this is
testosterone declines but if you look at
like new businesses that are created you
know you hear about these stories of
startups and you know uber you know
facebook google actually over time if
you look at the number of new businesses
that are created it's been declining
over time um as people get wealthier you
know you have more regulations you have
a bigger welfare state
maybe these things make sense at some
level but also it's maybe it's like you
basically you're the casino you're like
one big if you're like a wealthy country
and you're like okay i'm just going to
cash it in and so i'm not going to have
economic growth but i'm just going to
like redistribute the wealth we already
have that's basically what you're doing
right you're like leaving the casino um
but yeah uh
it is concerning that over time wealthy
societies become stagnant and complacent
like this where they have regulations
that make growth really hard
um
there's i i guess like even hormonal
changes like literally the testosterone
goes down over time yeah 100 yeah you
wrote a piece about popularizers or
intellectual market makers uh what do
you mean by popularizers and then what
is this idea of like an intellectual
marketplace yeah so if you think about
what a market maker does right a market
maker somebody provides a service in the
market um you go like robin hood or
something
uh you can see that you can like buy any
stock you want anytime you want why is
that possible it's because there's
somebody who provides a service where
they're gonna buy your stock at let's
say one a dollar in one cent they're
gonna sell it at 99 cents they're gonna
make two cents of money off of that um
so you're paying a little bit of fee to
them to provide liquidity to take it off
your hands anytime you want um and so
you don't have to wait for another
counterparty to come around to be able
to sell that stock um i think if you
think about what popularizers do so
think people think like public
intellectuals pop site book writers i
think they're actually provide a very
similar service in the intellectual
sphere so you think of somebody like
malcolm gladwell right how does he how
did he achieve his notoriety well one of
the things is he takes this undiscovered
study about hockey players and their
birthdays
and he converts it into this new york
times bestselling book called outliers
and then he makes money off that spread
right and the thing about market makers
is they provide an actual useful service
so it's useful to both all three
counterparties um similar with like
gladwell brought up the profile of this
guy who wrote a study about hockey
players he brought like a useful book to
consumers and he's making money off that
spread
um and people degrade these kinds of
popularity oh it's like alternative
right you hear talk about like you all
know how race book it's like oh these
are ideas people already had
i think people missed the point that if
you don't have these intellectual market
makers if you don't have these public
intellectuals
you don't have liquidity market makers
provide liquidity right so you don't
have liquidity in the intellectual
marketplace and you don't have liquidity
ideas can be exchanged there's not as
much turnover and ideas people aren't
exposed to ideas just if you didn't have
market makers you couldn't like easily
buy stocks off robin hood so people um
when you think about it this way you
understand the value that these
popularities are providing you don't
just think of them like oh they're just
like regurgitating information
the
idea of a popularizer being an
intellectual market maker uh is
not new like you said it in a way that
that is new uh yeah
it is itself an example of intellectual
market making well guess who uh is
probably the world's most famous
popularizer
thomas edison
oh interesting seymour thomas edison's
entire
model
was that he would go find young
incredibly smart uh
innovators
get their ideas bring them in
fund them yeah and then help popularize
those ideas huh so edison didn't create
electricity edison didn't create you
know all these different things but in
some way it was a cross between like in
today's society um
y combinator and like
joe rogan's podcast
coming together
to
discover fund
operationally you know increase uh
productivity and then popularize the
idea and so in some way it wasn't write
a book
right it was more so like uh what we
would consider action or or productivity
but like at the end of the day like
that's that was what the business he was
in
yeah yeah it's also sort said like peter
two right like him scouting out talent
it's like he's
basically market making between the
talony scouts and the companies he
creates and you know funds so yeah
actually that's a really interesting way
to think about people who spot talent
and who spot new ideas innovators if you
have to choose between finding somebody
who is high performance high intellect
outlier potential or like high
volatility as we talked about earlier
or somebody who is well versed at
management and all this stuff the
difference between the best investors in
the world and the top quartile
is that the best investors
will pick the high volatility person
interesting not the high management
person how do you find people who are
high volatility what is it about their
past about their presentation that you
can tell this person's gonna the pattern
there almost is no pattern which is why
they're high volatile um
and uh probably the place that i find
the most of them is on twitter
interesting and they're usually talking
about stuff that uh they almost never
have a lot of followers right or or a
lower amount than you would expect
they're usually talking about weird
things uh and uh they usually actually
you can tell if you read through their
tweets they are high volatility um like
there's times where you can tell like
okay this is like uh maybe in the
content there's volatility so like
they're talking about this one extreme
thing then they're talking about another
extreme thing they're talking about this
other and like you're like
oh this is kind of all over the place
but you realize it's because they're
like a curious person or they're like
high-end they're trying to learn or
whatever uh there's volatility from an
emotional standpoint so there's they get
really excited they get not so excited
and like that high uh emotion volatility
ends up uh being something that you can
tell if somebody's created an uh tweeted
enough or something on twitter and then
when you talk to them you definitely can
um and then also uh i think that you can
tell based on ambition
so if you talk to somebody for long
enough you can tell
high volatility uh to the upside in
terms of they're very very ambitious
about some things and then there is
almost a complete counterbalance in that
they are uh so disinterested and uh
completely
uh bored by things that actually usually
society would be you know uh super
excited about so like a good example
would be i want to solve this really
really hard problem and i don't care if
i make any money
right and you're like man
those like those are two different ends
of uh kind of the goal
you know spectrum and most people
optimize for the money and like if it
happens to be a hard problem then like
cool that's intellectually stimulating
so there's a bunch of different
frameworks and i think that what you end
up just realizing is uh
uh it's kind of like a volatility index
like when the vix spikes like shit's
getting crazy
people have like a personal vic score
almost right and you talk to him and
you're just like
this person is within this like narrow
band or this person is not within the
narrow band and like not being in the
narrow band again like could have many
different outcomes it could be like
genius [ __ ] right like insane you know
rational optimist
but i think over time people have uh who
look for these
types of folks they just realize like
the one thing that everyone is certain
is avoid the people within the band
because uh
that's not where the outlier outcomes
are right yeah
yeah and you know one worry you could
have
is we have institutions that
homogenize so much
that you're not reducing
the media like the median on me like the
median value of somebody who like goes
to harvard maybe increases like maybe
they're learning valuable skills but if
you've gotten rid of the tail outcomes
and most of the value comes from those
tail outcomes yeah then you've actually
done something very bad i this guy wrote
a really interesting you can ask a
question of like why are there
when shakespeare was around the human
population was like less than a billion
it was like significantly less when
shakespeare was around and you know he's
like said to be the greatest writer of
all time or just go back to like
einstein edison these people around the
human population was a lot lower and
these people are just like super
outliers these kinds of people almost
don't seem to exist today right like
there's no writer who says good at
shakespeare there's uh elon musk is like
a mentorship to medicine but like
scientists was as good as einstein right
and one thing you that could be
happening
is you have institutions uh that if you
think they're like writers they go to
like masters of fine arts right okay and
they'll live in brooklyn so everybody
who could be writing a really brilliant
book they're not out there like melville
you know like becoming fishermen or
something and they're like getting
exposure to a idea that gives them the
idea right uh
um
writes them like magnum opus on you know
uh
they're just like they're literally
living the same lifestyle as everybody
who's trying to do the same thing same
as like going to harvard right same
network same ideas
same skill set so if we're reducing the
volatility of mercifulization
um
through these kinds of homogenizing
institutions i think we make a mistake
by just saying oh the median hasn't
decreased you're you're forgetting that
what
um you know somebody asked me a question
like why don't we why do we only have
one elon musk
there should be like a thousand of them
going around like what happened to the
rest of them right did we just kill off
the tail of that kind of outcome and
then only one of them survived whatever
filter we had there
yeah i think that we probably have more
than one there's just one who lined it
all up yep
ambition
uh capital network
courage
right like it takes a lot of different
things
but there's probably other people
like that
and you know
you could look and say uh
ambition is like a great one
what's ambitious to one person is not
ambitious to another person and uh
in many cases over history there's been
people who have been highly ambitious uh
and have come to conclusions that ended
up being really important but at the
time they were laughed at
right um
i'm gonna forget the uh the name of the
person uh but there's a an individual
who uh
the world is round uh but
the rest of the solar system does not
revolve around the earth revolves around
the sun
i was killed for it
yeah what was it copernicus
i forget
and so when you think of that
like
now we're like duh
right but at the time crazy you're
insane so it then begs the question like
what insane thing exists today
that you actually think
is more likely right than wrong
and so there's things that probably in
the tech world we think of you know
around solving problems or whatever
but there's probably counter cultural
things uh in society
that seem absolutely [ __ ] bananas
and then
20 years from now 30 years 50 years you
know during our lifetime we'll be like
oh i can't believe we didn't realize
that yeah
i do wonder i mean there's this movement
of like trad i don't know if you've seen
the stuff no what is it um basically
like living living like people
living like people lived like many
decades or centuries ago but with like
modern technology how would you do that
well no no no this is not like amish
like you still adopt modern technology
but you also have i guess more
traditional lifestyles in terms of like
gender norms or
um
or
like
or or just you know like what kinds of
careers you choose things like that so
um so you still have like a cell phone
you solve a lecture yeah you still have
whatever right but it's but you have you
basically you have like a lot of kids or
something okay yeah
um
and yeah it sounds weird uh actually
that's not even that novel but i do
think that the way we like organize
families and communities today
there is an element to it which is maybe
over time it will seem like that was
like a really isolating way to live
and you know if you if your ancestors
were going to see how you lived there
would be like they'd be super
uh
they'd be super anxious about the fact
that
you're just like alone most of the day
right when they're trapped in a house
what you were telling me about you know
going to the tournament museum in new
york like 10 people in a small room okay
that sounds maybe that's too much right
but then just like millions of people
living in an apartment by themselves it
also probably sounds a bit dystopic to
them from the opposite perspective
and also probably the free to cheap
information that you consume on your
phone some of that would uh they would
not approve of right so i think over
time like the way we think of
i wouldn't be surprised if
fundamentally some of the ways we like
live organized families communities
today would be looked at in the future
as
um yeah that was like a really isolating
and weird way to live at the time yeah
100
and it also uh if you look at a lot of
society's problems like
probably could be boiled down to like a
great way to solve it would just be
better parenting
but you ever said a news story and you
see somebody doing something and you're
like man if that person had a certain
type of parent like they'd smack them in
the face right just be like what are you
doing yeah and uh
again
that's not the solution to everything
right but like
that is the proxy for uh
[Music]
there's definitely some something there
around
uh family
parenting the way people are raised like
all this stuff and like some of it's
positive right like there is this
element of uh the way that some people
were raised 50 years ago was actually
bad for the kid right like it [ __ ]
them up as they grew up but then there
are some other things like hey maybe we
need more you know discipline or
whatever um and it's some of it's the
story's oldest time like
how many
different decades was the story like oh
young
energetic you know lost unorganized man
joins military gets disciplined becomes
productive member of society like that's
just a story that has always existed for
a long time uh but there's other
examples of it in society and so like i
always want go back to just like
again how many of the problems are
fixed or addressed via social
medias versus uh legal versus like
technology
and the truth is that like actually a
lot of our problems in society that are
like fundamental problems that people
feel on a day-to-day basis they're not
technology problems
yeah usually these other things yeah but
parenting by the way is one thing where
i have like
um where i think we're really doing a
bad job
in some ways it's like much better than
the past right like kids are not getting
like beaten or something so actually
there was um dan carlin has a book on uh
history where he says i think he
estimated that like
more than half the kids who have ever
lived were like sexually abused or in
other way like physically abused because
um i forgot what his evidence was but
yeah like i think
there's some pretty dark things if you
look back at history like how kids were
treated so in many ways we've like made
a lot of progress but i think one thing
i had this lady come on my podcast um
she's some she's the founder of a
movement called taking children
seriously
and the idea is
if you think about the way we treat
children in terms of the rights we give
them
they're if you treat an adult this way
it would just be a huge infringement on
somebody's own personal autonomy like
trapping
a 16 year old in a government building
from nine to five and this like
basically this person and if you look at
the outcomes of education like it's
basically
it's 100
prison for most kids yeah not every kid
there's again there's a reason why
traditional education is important for
certain uh uh occupational stuff but
you're telling a child
sit down and shut up for eight hours a
day like that's not natural it gets even
darker if you listen to these stories
about um chinese education
um there's this guy has a doorman he has
a great review of this book called
literal children where he talks about
this lady um
she she like moves from america to china
and her kid is like enrolled in a
chinese free school and like there's a
craze
one of the things that happens is he's
forced to draw um raindrops or tiered
yeah raindrops but it's like hours a day
they ought to be the exact same shape
and form and if you like mess up you
like try to like actually make this
figure a different anyway they punish
you or one time her kid was just
he hated eggs so
the school like fed the kids eggs and
the kid really hated eggs so they like
physically force feed him eggs so that
he can get over his aversion and when
the mother goes to the teacher and she's
like yo what the [ __ ] are you doing she
the teacher is like never talk back to a
teacher ever
like the adults have complete authority
the children are treated like [ __ ] um
yeah so but even like even if you think
about like i
if you look at the outcomes of education
in the u.s right if you ask people who
have taken spanish in high school or
middle school just like remember
anything about uh spanish
right
i took four years of spanish in high
school i was in mexico city i'd have
like i barely referred anything but just
like stuff like how many years of
civilized education people are like we
need to increase this education or
something how many years have some of
this education in history are you
already giving the kids and you look at
like polls you ask people what are the
three branches of government or like how
many branches of government do we have
it's like a small minority know that so
educators is like completely useless or
mostly useless outside of just like the
basic neuroscience literacy
and we're forcing kids to be miserable
for hours a day
um social control as well like what do
you do with the kids right right yeah
yeah like in some way uh many parents
look at school as almost like a
babysitter
right it's like i gotta go to work and
and
again you can't lose the other side of
this equation which is like
if the parents couldn't go to work
because they had to watch their kid like
that's not an option they got to go to
work so then it's like okay well what
are the what is the cost
to doing something with the child while
you're at work yeah that's why i found a
child labor
child labor yes all right explain this
jesus today's episode is brought to you
by altoi all right have you wanted to
buy bitcoin or over 200 other
cryptocurrencies in your retirement
account well now you can with alto ira
they allow you to buy bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies in a tax-advantaged way
there's no account or set up fees and
it's super simple to get started you can
go today to altoira dot com slash pomp
to get started alto ira dot com slash
pomp invest in bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies in your retirement
account and get all the tax advantages
while still holding digital currencies
alto ira.com
so people talk about child labor they
think about the last time child labor
was legal which was when they were like
getting their hands burned off in some
contract you know what i mean like some
type of shop
exactly china but like the nike doesn't
do that
they claim
yeah um
so that's what they think of right but
that's not what jobs are today
like the
adults at the time are doing the same
kind of work today it's like he would
work at a donut shop or he would like
work at mcdonald's or walmart or
something
and
i would claim that the skills you learn
at mcdonald's actually i i think
this is actually something they do
really well but it's like showing up on
time being responsive being having like
social skills being having like
self-control i would say that that's
more valuable than any given day in like
a public education system
um
so i agree except for i'm gonna twist
this one way i would look at it less as
like george and mcdonald's go work at uh
walmart or whatever uh and i think
again i have a eight-month-old daughter
so i'm like actively thinking through
but i've got time to kind of figure out
you know
how to handle this uh
i thought it was like apprenticeship yep
no i agree like apprenticeship model
feels like uh a great way for people to
learn without the downsides of like sit
down shut up don't talk for eight hours
right and um
when you say this whole like taking kids
seriously you know type movement it's
just treat them like an adult and i
think they begin to emulate what adults
do yeah right like if you treat a kid
like a one-year-old kid uh and you're
constantly telling them no and this and
that like they just act
exactly like you're treating them if you
treated a 25 year old like you do a 14
year old and you also they i guess they
didn't realize they were 25 i don't know
it's a weird thought no no they but you
know what i mean still if you still
treat them like they're 14 they
they uh revert towards exactly 14 year
olds which also raises the possibility
that if you treated 14 year olds now
like they were 25 right so
that you know like basically they're the
beginning of their career not that
they're like stuck in this infant
primordial state of constantly getting
more education in ways that don't seem
related to any obvious career but just
like okay you're 14 you're gonna get an
apprenticeship you're gonna like go
intern at some you know like a
programming firm or finance or whatever
right like you're gonna like actually
get up if you look through history you
look at how um education worked in
um
uh
how like careers worked and let's say
like medieval times or something you
know it was like you apprenticed for a
blacks you apprenticed for the person
you want to become in your career and
parents would pay the person for the
privilege of having their child work for
them uh because they realize that the
education like the first-hand education
is way more important there actually is
a scientist um i forget his first name
but it's called this two sigma problem
where he discovered that
one-on-one tutoring is two standard
deviations more effective than the
current education system where you have
like 20 kids in a school so just if you
just had replace currencies which is
like you give everybody an apprentice
the problem is the way that um
the way that the labor market
regulations work here um
like with internships that are unpaid
your the law literally says you're not
allowed to get any economic value from
them if you get economic value from them
you're not allowed to have them have
that be an unpaid intern
but they're getting value out of they're
getting experience which is like super
valuable to them that's not legally
allowed for you to give them that
experience and it's um and yeah so
basically this puts a huge drag on
people who would use this as like a
lover to climb up in there warren
buffett right like somebody asked them
uh hey can i come work for you for free
and he said no that'd be too expensive
right like like you're taking my time
right which kind of fits along this um
but yeah i just think
if you took a 1450 okay by the way i was
a [ __ ] 14 year old kid right and
most especially young boys but most kids
are their brains aren't formed like they
act like idiots right they got too much
energy like all these things uh but
i'm willing to bet i would have learned
more if you said to me hey every six
months you're gonna go you know you're
gonna work at this place you're gonna do
this you're gonna do this you're gonna
do this and uh you could say okay cool
you know when i was 14 uh there was like
three or four things i thought could be
cool potential uh like job paths and you
say cool you're gonna go spend you know
every day for you know every weekday
you're gonna go spend with these people
and you're basically gonna have this
apprenticeship and you're gonna do
whatever they need you to do
uh and at the end of two or three years
i probably have a pretty damn good
education from like real world exposure
but also i'd probably know better as to
what i was most interested in
and so like are we doing people a
disservice by putting them through high
school they graduate and it's like go to
college and like figure it out in
college
well like
where you go to college pretty damn
important you know uh decisions where's
your study whether you go to college or
not pretty important decision right and
so you just don't have any exposure
really because you know
every once in a while i get an email
from somebody who's like a high school
senior and they're like hey i want to do
like a summer internship or something
and i'm like okay
but there's like no model for that
and by the time you're
a senior
that summer is like the summer before
you go to college you already made all
this session yeah
so like what if you were like a freshman
sophomore yeah and different the um
the crazy thing is not only that are you
forced to kind of decide on those kinds
of things when you're pretty young um in
a way that is
you had to do it without the experience
of what those careers are like um
but
the
the the the amount of time it takes to
go through that process like if you talk
to a smart
kid in high school and you're like okay
how long did it take you to apply to
colleges and stuff it is a huge
bureaucratic time consuming process
these kids could otherwise be spending
time doing a whole bunch of cool side
projects that are going to really help
their career i mean in programming it's
like you start a github account in your
high school and you start programming
some things people are going to notice
and they're going to be oppressed right
it's like a proof of work um you don't
have time for that if you're applying to
colleges and writing these [ __ ]
essays um where you got to pretend that
you're going to the college for the
reason other than the obvious reason you
go to a prestigious college which is you
want to make a lot of money right did
you see um ah maybe it's morgan housel
somebody on twitter recently was like
high school uh
like you fail because you didn't meet
the 10 page minimum essay requirement
like real world uh
promotion you sent me a two bullet point
email right or like whatever it was and
it was basically just like like what are
we talking about here right is you
actually in the professional world get
rewarded for being able to communicate
clearly and concisely yep but somehow
like we all did it in high school how do
i do like 1.5 uh space right like ah
they're gonna be able to tell 12 point
font verse 12.5 font right like like can
we play with the margins like you play
like you're just like i'm literally
wasting time yep right doing dumb [ __ ]
uh to try to meet some you know uh made
up requirement yeah yeah i think over
time hopefully there will be more ways
to signal
that if you think about what is
education signaling right um
the main reason go to college is send a
signal to future employers and signal is
i'm intelligent i'm conscientious i work
i can work hard i can do like tasks that
are kind of boring and maybe not
directly useful i can just work hard at
them and i'm conformist right um
which is like a thing that probably
employers care about uh it has a
negative connotation but it's like i'm
not gonna like you know like disrupt the
workplace or something um
hopefully uh there's ways to signal
intelligence consciousness and
conscientiousness early on and better
than college and if that happens the
whole oligopoly we have of education you
know the the schools that receive
federal funding are the ones that get to
determine if another school can receive
federal funding for education it's a
total like just a total oligopoly
anyways so if if for programming let's
say github your github resume becomes
more important uh than where you went to
college which it should be right like
what you can actually do there's a clear
legible signal of that
then um hopefully
the the power of these
like people won't feel forced to go
attend like a four-year university uh
degree that way there was actually the i
had this guy on the podcast cut young i
don't know if you've seen he's
he did something called the mit
challenge where if you look at mit's
curriculum in all its courses to their
credit they've made it all open source
so all the lectures all the exams
they're all open source so he's like
okay let me see if i can speed around
mit's computer science curriculum
in one year he goes through all four
years of cs classes at mit
he i think he was going at an insane
pace it was like one class a week
um it just like worked all day all night
at it and
he would self-administer the exams and
like
if he he would like as long as he didn't
fail those exams and those homeworks he
would like say i've graduated this
course and so he did that it took him a
year and he got like all kinds of insane
programming job offers after that
because like that's a novel volatile
thing to do people notice that it's
almost a better signal than actually
going to mit
um hopefully over time you can do more
of those kinds of things there is like
two years of work in four years of
college maybe two years yeah right yeah
like there's a lot of [ __ ] that goes
on i would be surprised if it's two
years
like that sounds like way too much yeah
i i'm pr i got an economics degree which
at the time uh i selected one because it
was going to be the shortest path to
getting a degree but also to uh had some
intellectual interest in it i think you
had to take eight credits there's like
eight classes jesus now you had to meet
other requirements or whatever you know
they fill it out to make it so it's not
just hey take these eight classes uh but
yeah like that that was it yeah the
unfortunate i think is they're adding at
least um at my university they're this
didn't happen with me
they're adding like more [ __ ]
classes you had to take as like a
general curriculum kind of thing like
one of the things they're gonna force
you to take in the future is
um sustainability classes or something
we already had to take
um global diversity or global cult you
know just like all kinds of these things
it's like kind of political propaganda
classes you have to take so
yeah it sounds good to the board of
trustees right and then you think like
what is the actual value we're
contributing to the student
um
yeah i actually i made it a part of
principle i never read a book i was
assigned in school
that's pretty good strategy i mean look
there's good books that uh people may
discuss but for the most part they're
probably not the ones that you're
interested right yeah
it's um i don't know it's a weird thing
would you do college again
it's that's an interesting question
because
you have to approach it from the
perspective of
not knowing what i know now but i know
now what even if i forgot everything i
know about computer science i know now
how i could teach myself those things or
what kinds of opportunities and
networking things i could do
to give myself a leg up and go through
things i've gone through much faster
i wouldn't know that when i was 17 and i
also wouldn't know
um
like i i don't know if i'd have the
discipline
and
the
the conscientiousness frankly to go
through that kind of stuff so i probably
would still go through college but i
think i had a different kind of degree i
probably wouldn't um and if i could like
know what i know now about just like how
to learn i wouldn't go through college
yeah
i'd go for the parties yeah
i like the social experience right yeah
the
education uh i mean maybe it helped um
one of my favorite experiences from
college uh uh i got deployed halfway
through school so i came back and so i
walked into
some kind of government or
politics class whatever it was and all
of a sudden somehow like the middle east
came up and i was sitting there and you
know my strategy was like just don't get
noticed in class um and uh probably
didn't take it nearly as seriously as i
should have or i would now
uh but the teacher started saying all
kinds of like crazy [ __ ] uh about uh
the middle east and like u.s relations
like all the stuff and everything and uh
one of my buddies was sitting next to me
and he like tapped me and he was like
like like what do you think and i don't
know it's all [ __ ] and then of
course like a [ __ ] jackass right he
he raises his head he goes well he was
just there so like he could tell us
and so like it was fascinating though
because like that was like
again that was one specific instance and
you know what ended up being five and a
half years total uh from start to finish
um
but like i probably was better verse
like me personally than the teacher
talked about that one
part of the class and then it made me
think i was like looking around the room
and we had people from all walks of life
and all those different things and i was
like
well what do you think right like what
do you think like how do like why can't
we make this less of like a lecture
where it's one person who's up there
who's just been a teacher their whole
life
why don't we all talk and i bet you i'm
gonna be able to learn a lot more from
some of these people than i am from the
teacher
and so some of it's like college itself
and then some of it is just like even
the uh the mechanisms that just like
replicate what was high school because
it's different in high school yes you
could learn from your classmates and
stuff but like the world experiences
aren't nearly as well developed as maybe
by the time you get to college and if
you have like freshmen and seniors
that are together right in a class
that's very different than like
i don't know how many freshmen in high
school are learning a lot from their
freshman classmates
except for if it's somebody who comes
from a different culture a different
place maybe has different life
experience but like that's not nearly as
much you've only been around for 14
years yeah right of which you probably
remember you know less than 10. so like
how much could you really have done and
then be able to articulate those ideas
is a little different right what was the
experience like going from these like
life and death situations in the
military um then to transitioning to
college where it's
a little bit contrived kind of uh you
know just like
it doesn't seem as
visceral as being in a military
situation
so i was in college
got deployed and came back to college
right so it was like what was the
transition like before and after
going there um
it wasn't real at first yeah like that
i've told story before but uh
i was in college i was playing football
went and uh went and got deployed and so
like
you kind of almost feel like it's almost
like a game a little bit and then the
first time that there was like a major
event while i was there uh somebody got
killed and you then get to the situation
like oh this is real right it's like it
changed the perspective uh but then
coming back um
i was there with a lot of older guys so
i was 20 i turned 21 uh in iraq uh these
guys probably the average age was like
27 28.
and so uh many of them married kids had
a house like just like life [ __ ] right
i was worried about like what's the
party on friday you know like a couple
weeks before these guys are worried
about like how do i pay my mortgage how
do i take care of my kids like whatever
so like you just like naturally mature
in a weird way like apprenticeship right
like you get exposed to certain things
um and then when i came back like there
was actually like a very barbell
response so on one side you're a 21 year
old kid who went to war and came back
like you are invincible
right
[ __ ] do all kinds of crazy stuff
on the other side you're like man like i
should take school more seriously right
like i'm gonna be here there's a real
world after this and so like i became
much more serious about like more like
intellectual things or whatever and so
like that's like a weird balance
because you're like uh you know hey you
came back and like you're i don't know i
got a motorcycle and would [ __ ] fly
around and like act like an idiot right
and like not from a sense of like i was
doing anything that was uh endangering
other people or whatever but like i
would go fast on a motorcycle and my
right hand is like because like you just
felt you know
uh implicitly like you know you can do
anything
at the same time though you become more
serious about like hey i actually want
to learn here right and so uh
it was weird too because i also came
back
uh and i was only there for one semester
with everyone i'd gone through college
with then they graduated so now it's
with myself and like a bunch of younger
people right and they're not that much
i'm gonna eat two years or whatever
but now all of a sudden like you're the
old person right and then like in a
college environment the age bracket is
like 18 to 22. yeah so if you are on the
higher end of that and you're around you
know 18 to 19 year olds like that's a
pretty big
psychology gap like all this stuff and
then the life experience and all that
and so it was uh it's the first time in
my life that i kind of was just like oh
[ __ ] we're all like we all die we all
get old we all like do all this stuff
and so it just added a layer of like
seriousness i think of just like all
right like you don't get to just party
and act like an idiot in college forever
you have to like go into the real world
and so like some degree like
if more people got you know not good war
but like could understand that i bet you
people would take it more seriously yeah
how old were you when you got back uh i
came back i was 21. oh so i went at 20
turned 21 overseas then came back
yeah yeah no that's um
when you are in college like you notice
the difference between
somebody who is like a freshman and
senior and then if you if you punctuate
that with a super intense experience
super life-orbiting experience like
going to the military it just
i i the psychology like your discipline
your motivation what you think is
important i can't imagine like the
difference well just think 18 to 22 of
like an average college student
difference and then imagine a 24 year
old who's has two years of work
experience yeah
like the 18 to 22 was already crazy
jumped 22 to 24 is actually a pretty
crazy job with two years of life
experience then go 18-24
like
you know kid versus you know uh young
adult right like it's completely
different and so i think uh
those years are like some of like the
highest volatility years right and
uh i don't actually know this is very
interesting i don't know very many
people
who
took
we'll call it the like safe path
out of college that reverted back
interesting to like high volatility
that's super decisions later because it
that's that's really interesting and i'm
curious why that is because in tech
you'll notice a lot of people will say
when they graduate college i'm going to
work on google for a few years i'm going
to start my own startup i'm only saving
up enough money that i have a nest egg
maybe i can like have a few months of
runway
and none of those people some of them
well some of them start companies they
just start the safe company yeah they
start to like hey i worked at google for
five years and now i'm gonna work on ad
optimization startup like cool
but none of them go and i'm gonna build
a nuclear power plant yeah right or very
like you know there's always the exams
the rule but like
there seems to be uh over time a
diminishing return to the high
volatility uh uh kind of path
and so if you're not gonna do it when
you're young you're almost never gonna
do it when you're old
except for external shock right
some life event happens and you like get
shaken out of one path and then you go
on another one
right and that i think is what we're
like have being in the military when
you're young i don't have experience but
like i can imagine how valuable that
experience would be
um because at the time when you're like
your brain is kind of still very plastic
and you could like
you could accumulate that
world you could accumulate that
experience in a way that like changes
your personality which wouldn't be
possible later on
i wonder if there's a way you can give
more people
a similar experience i guess maybe they
can all just join the military but
i don't know if people talk about gap
years i don't know how well they work at
doing making you more serious maybe you
just need to like work for a year out of
high school just so you become a little
more serious a little more motivated you
have an understanding of
how can i be successful and
do good things in the world if you strip
away
uh obstacles around money and uh other
obligations right there's plenty of
people who have to work whether in
college support their families whatever
but like just if you say hey we got a
blank slate everyone's on the same uh
kind of plane uh which is not how life
is but let's just say it was uh and you
said like what are the options of people
to go get the seriousness or go get the
experience there is this like ascending
level of severity so on one end maybe
it's like go get a job then there's like
travel to other cultures right for a
week or two weeks or whatever and get
exposed to a bunch of them then there's
like go live in another culture and then
maybe there's like you know go live in
another culture during a time of war
right or like however like that arc is
uh
and ultimately i think
one
most people don't do it because like
it's weird it breaks like the societal
like just go to college like stop being
weird right and like get your degree and
go get a job
um
the highest end of the spectrum
usually the people who are willing to do
that are not the people who have other
opportunities like that's another thing
is that most people who join the
military when they're young
they're not like should i go to harvard
or should i join the infantry right like
that's not like that's not the uh the
trade-off um and
so what naturally happens is like they
get pulled down on the severity curve
harvard versus
military is almost never an option maybe
it's like harvard versus west point i
want to go be an officer or something
right
harvard verse uh
go get a job
is almost maybe a tech company but like
for the most part that's not a thing
harvard verse like go live in another
culture
again not likely but maybe i'll go to
harvard and i'll study abroad for a
semester
right and so like people will get some
of that like weird experience but again
it pulls in
the tails of the comparison and gets it
gets you within that band i have this i
know this guy who's he's a 19 year old
just genius kid
um he's done some really impressive like
he helped me with the um spf interview
but also he's like he's doing some
really impressive things like the
smartest 19 year old i i know
and so he took a gap year he worked for
bern hobart uh he's like his second in
command there but
the so now he's
now he's considering what to do next and
he's like i think i'm gonna go to
college i'm like dude you have you could
literally you have a better career now
than somebody who goes to even the most
elite universities will have years after
they graduate like the amount of people
who know who you are and could like get
you something but just um
the social aspect of college this is it
yes because
for somebody who's already mature
um at that point at that age
your your high school friends are just
not gonna like have that level of
ambition and maturity um but i was
arguing you're not even get that in
college like my social life is much
better now outside of college than it
was in college just because the people i
hang out with are like 26 30 kind of you
know older people
um and i said like i feel like you're
probably gonna be similar and i feel
like a lot of these people who are going
to be at the sales um
yeah i i i think their social life even
would be better outside of college or
they can find the right groups yeah well
it's uh intentionality versus
probability right like you can
intentionally go create a social group
or intentionally go try to break into a
social group uh versus college like uh
you ever noticed that in college
everyone just hangs out with people from
their dorm yeah
like
who they ran into at orientation how
much of your life time like you know uh
uh uh
information like all these different
things was determined by like i don't
know like a random you know lottery
as to like who you got put in as your
college roommate and who lived down the
hall yep yep yeah right and so like some
of it's like hey it doesn't matter who
it was you were going to become friends
with people around you because you want
to have a social life uh but a lot of it
is like man if you think back like was
that
the highly optimized decision like
probably not yeah and it takes a lot to
be the weirdo who doesn't hang out with
the people you know doesn't hang out
with their college roommate or doesn't
hang out with the people in their dorm
uh and instead intentionally goes and
seeks out a different group of you know
friends that they want to spend time
because they think they can learn from
or whatever yeah yeah but no cigarette
well it's just like that's what most
people like oh that's a nerd right like
it's just even the way people talk about
it it has like a negative kind of
connotation to it but like it shouldn't
be that way yeah yeah by the way i i i
heard somewhere that men mature much
later than women
when they finish you can ask my wife she
will confirm that
yeah
but when they finish their brain
development
and so you have this period when like uh
people are 18 or 19 or something and the
women are already like
their brain
development is complete and the guys are
just
you know like
yeah exactly so it is like a strange
time even that way where like
the women are like as mature as like a
guy's like when they're 25 or something
right and part of that is the reason why
they seek out like older people as well
but yeah because the guys that age are
just idiots uh yeah if you think about
uh again generalized but like if you
think of the average 18 to 22 year old
male put into a social situation like a
college party yeah
there's like an insane increase of dumb
[ __ ] that they are willing to do
for
to make people laugh to get social
status to get approval like to do all
this stuff and then you're like all
right well if you take that person out
and you like put them in like the
workforce they would be just like a
normal person yeah right it's like some
of it's just like social situation stuff
but also like yeah you probably did a
bunch of [ __ ] when you're 18 22 years
old that you would never do 25 or later
because your brain just was developed
yeah yeah risk is different right like
all that stuff oh yeah
let me ask you a question all right go
ahead so
how does bitcoin increase the number of
i thought we were gonna get through the
whole thing with no bitcoin all right
good well now i'm curious about this how
does it uh increase the amount of goods
and services in the world so we talked
about like google maps for example right
it's like okay they did a virtual
product it makes economic transition uh
transactions that otherwise wouldn't be
possible happen it like saves his time
he can use that time to do other things
all kinds of other like benefits
what is that for bitcoin
well i think the single most important
piece is bitcoin gives people back their
time
so if you think of money money is just
time and uh you work
to get economic value that you then want
to hold the more economic value that you
hold the less that you have to rent out
your time or spend your time to get more
economic value so think of it in terms
of rich people
they have the freedom of time they can
go do what they want they can travel
they can spend it however they want
they're not beholden to i have to go to
my nine-to-five job and make economic
values so i can pay my bills and do all
this yeah so the more
the money or economic value that you
hold the more time that you have in
terms of free time
the reason why that's important is
because today the money loses value
so if i have a hundred dollars in 1990
and i hold it for 20 years it buys me
less goods and services so there's this
constant feeling of like i can never get
ahead it's the rat race right now
50 plus percent 55 of american citizens
invest they have some investable asset
and so the goal is for those investable
assets to outpace the devaluation of the
currency and so stock market goes up
real estate goes up commodities bonds
whatever right so i get some
ability to outpace it but 45 of
americans have no investments they just
have cash the paycheck to paycheck or
they just have 100 of their wealth in
cash those people have gotten worse off
over the years and then if you look in
the last two and a half years
inflation
is now at you know eight point five nine
point one percent but that's on top of
the five to seven percent inflation from
last year some of this compounding
effect and so while the devaluation of
the currency has accelerated wage growth
hasn't kept up so if you were getting
paid ten dollars an hour in 2019 10 an
hour in 2020 10 an hour in 2021 and 10
an hour in 2022 you're actually getting
paid less money today than you were back
in 2019
because your purchasing power has gone
down right right so what bitcoin does is
bitcoin just simply says if you go to
work and
you earn money you can now save it and
no one can devalue it
right okay um
but given the volatility
in its price it sounds like you're
saying um correct me if i'm wrong but
that it gives you like a stable way to
store your
uh
like a low volatility way to like store
your savings is the single most
important thing for society right but
given the recent volatility
there is no volatility
okay
people the only volatility is how many
dollars people are willing to give you
for it
it's the exchange price that's volatile
or is it a dollar volatile oh less than
bitcoin yeah but i would argue it's not
because
if i had let's say 10
and i wanted to go buy goods and
services in 2020 january 2020 and i
showed up today and i wanted to buy ten
dollars with the goods and services i
could buy less
right the dollar has devalued against
those goods and services but couldn't
you say the same thing like if you're
using that as a way to if you're
comparing them to goods and services
bitcoin in 2020 if i have the one
bitcoin right and now i try to go buy
something i can buy more goods and
services with that one bitcoin the
purchasing power of bitcoin appreciates
over time the purchasing power of the
dollar depreciates
so it could be that it increases in
value over time but also that it's more
volatile
it's like but it's not volatile that's
the key is we think of volatility
as
an exchange rate
right so for example people look at the
uh housing market
how many dollars will somebody give me
for this house in 2019 2020 21 2022
but the house is not volatile the house
is a [ __ ] house got four walls got a
roof and people still live in it
the volatility is the exchange rate two
dollars now that's how finance is based
right so it's not like uh oh we
shouldn't think about you know uh
exchange rates or anything like that but
when you price the home
you don't say like it's worth one home
now it's worth two homes right you say
no it's worth you know a hundred
thousand dollars for a hundred twenty
five thousand it's worth seventy five
thousand so there's an exchange back
into a common unit of account
okay but
if you take dollars out of it i just
said how many apples could you buy with
one bitcoin that amount again is still
an exchange rate but even even if you
take dollars out of it even compared to
goods and services it seems more
volatile than
but it's volatile to the upside where
the dollar is volatile to the downside
yeah unless you bought at the peak
well if you're trying to optimize on a
single day-to-day basis like basically
if you say hey i bought uh one bitcoin
today and then i try to spend it in a
week you're a day trader yeah right but
nobody says oh i got a dollar 12 months
ago and now it's down 10
in purchasing power right like the
dollar is horrible and no one should use
dollars but the 45 of people you
mentioned who don't have any um
investments
they're probably the kind of people who
don't who who are um who can't just hold
for
uh for a long time like they're the kind
of people who need to be liquid on a
very regular basis like they get a
paycheck they need to use it so for
those kinds of people how is bitcoin a
solution if you need to hold it for a
long time to see that upside well the
first thing is uh bitcoin is a
technology solution the actual solution
to most people's problems is financial
education right so if you think about it
like most people the 45 of americans if
they knew hey those dollars you're
holding are eroding away and purchasing
power and you literally are getting paid
less money than you were two years ago
like they probably would make changes
right or the theory would be that if
they had the education they would make
changes the first problem is like they
just don't know that
and so like why don't we teach that in
school
right like that like better than
teaching like all the [ __ ] like why
don't we just teach people hey
the currency is created in a way where
it has to be devalued and therefore do
not hold this for 100 of your wealth for
very long periods of time right and so
this also goes back to the whole thing
of like i don't think there's very many
people that say like hey bitcoin today
is a superior
means of payment and like you should go
take 100 of the money you want to spend
tomorrow and go put it in bitcoin and
like hope it doesn't go up or down yeah
right i think instead where you're
seeing a lot of adoption is actually as
a
uh store value
so a lot of people are coming in and you
see it in the data like 60 plus percent
of bitcoin in circulation hasn't moved
in a year
right so people are for majority of the
bitcoin that is held by uh folks they're
buying it and holding it for long
periods of time okay and so
the theory and again takes time to see
if this plays out is that you ha as a
currency you have to establish yourself
as a store of value before you can ever
become a means of exchange
okay but so you you think eventually
bitcoin will be a medium exchange or let
me ask you this do you trust computers
or people
um
for what i guess would be the question
for
well
forget for a second what you think you
trust computers over people for majority
of things in your life sure right like
your music recommendations your search
results your maps like all these
different things right
today
billions of people around the world put
faith
in 12 people at the fomc to [ __ ]
guess
the future yep
talk about something that exists today
that 100 years from now we're going to
look back and be like what happened
like there are 12 people
who
are not elected by the people they're
just appointed that go into a conference
room and they periodically look at a
bunch of data which usually is backwards
looking data
and
there's a lot of problems with the data
and they lick their finger put in the
air and they say we think we should do x
for the future
and like you don't have to look very far
just look over the last few years these
people have no clue what's going on
right and one of my favorite examples is
like
if you asked a five-year-old
positive or negative
talking about gdp for a quarter it's a
50 50 shot
right like like positive negative
in the last two quarters
the economist had said positive
and it came in negative
right so like again i don't expect
people to be like oh they have to always
get you know if it's 1.2 they have to
get 1.2 right of course it's it's hard
it's a complex machine there's moving
parts there's tons of data that changes
whatever and if they say 1.2 and it
comes at a 1.4 or 1 or 1.0 like okay
sure they at least directionally got it
right
but when you start to see like they
think it's positive that it comes in
negative
it's like why like who cares what they
say next time right now like they have
no clue
but it's not their fault like i don't
think there's like some grand conspiracy
where they like go in a room and they're
like you know it'd be [ __ ] our best
strategy let's say positive even though
we think it's gonna be negative like i
literally think they think it's gonna be
positive and then stuff goes wrong and
so the reason why i say that is like
if automation is a very
non-controversial thing
the single most important institution in
your life that is human-led that [ __ ]
up your life
is central banks
not because they want to
but that is what happens
so why don't we automate it
well bitcoin already did that
the most disciplined monetary policy
over the entire covid inflation
recession all this [ __ ] has been bitcoin
it's the only one that didn't change
everyone else changed
the fed they pivoted then they went qe
then they came back now they're doing qt
uh the ecb said we're not gonna do qt oh
now they're doing it we're not gonna
take our interest rates from negative to
zero like all these things they all
change their minds but still relative to
goods and services the exchange rate is
less volatile
for the
given all this volatility and how people
react so volatility uh not good or bad
works in both directions operations
right but it is bad in the sense if you
just want
to be able to
you know if you want the liquidity it's
not it's volatility by itself is not bad
if volatility to the upside like bitcoin
sure right is actually a good thing if
you're holding bitcoin right because
everything around you gets cheaper and
so if you go back to january 2020 before
everything happened and you said knowing
everything we know now you can put your
assets in one currency
you put in bitcoin
do you still think that bitcoin is a
good inflation hedge or i think that
what we are learning like
bitcoin
served as a fantastic uh debasement
hedge
and i think over time like my views have
evolved on this and i think the market
is just getting smarter as we get more
data which would i think is a healthy
thing
inflation hedge assets are actually a
very interesting thing inflation hedge
assets move before the inflation comes
right so like one of the things that
people forget is like
if i think inflation is coming
i do not wait for the inflation to get
here and then move my assets i move them
in anticipation so this is why in q3 and
q4 of 2020 you saw paul tudor jones
stanley druckenmiller like all these
wall street legends talking about we
think inflation's going to be high we're
going to go and we're going to put our
assets in inflation hedges uh paul tudor
jones famously said you know bitcoin's
gonna be the fastest horse in this
bucket
well guess what bitcoin did it went from
ten thousand to sixty four thousand
dollars in a matter of like five months
right
well that tells me that there was a fix
supply asset tons of demand coming in
inflation was still like two three
percent
we didn't get the first five percent cpi
print until june of 2021. so bitcoin
moved before
and then here came five plus percent for
you know what is now over a year
now
bitcoin has also come down since
november it peaked at 69 000 in november
and uh it's now trading called 20 23 000
whatever it is
why did it come down inflation's still
high because markets are forward-looking
so just like why did the stock market
come down it's because the fed said we
were going to destroy demand
and the second they started to say that
what did sophisticated investors do like
we're [ __ ] out okay so but you so you
think the reason one of the reasons
bitcoin declined is the prospect for
inflation went down not the prospect for
inflation it's that the fed
is signaling that they're going to do
everything they can to create tighter
financial conditions and they're going
to destroy demand and so again it's it's
pretty unique in that like bitcoin
hasn't been any different than other
assets right in some way when you have
market intervention like we have uh
especially over the last two two and a
half years all asset correlations start
to trend towards one mm-hmm so bitcoin
up until 2020 was like a non-correlated
asset right correlations were you know
0.15 or whatever was just it's a math
equation it's not up for debate like you
just measured the math
in 2020 until today correlations have
gone through the roof and now you just
overlay you know s p and bitcoin or s p
and nasdaq or whatever and they just
trade like almost lockstep
but so do a lot of assets because what's
happened is we have a manipulated market
and sophisticated investors treat all of
the assets in a similar fashion
right in march of 2020 bitcoin's
correlation to other assets went through
the roof there's a liquidity crisis yeah
yeah people sold everything they wanted
dollars
so if if you think of it today the
dollar is at a 20-year high against you
know the dollar index against other fiat
currencies people want dollars so if
people want dollars the dollar
strengthens well if all these other
assets are priced in dollars everything
goes down yeah right i guess if you're
um looking for a hedge you probably want
it to be not correlated to other assets
you might you might you hold the problem
is that there is no asset right now
right in these situations like basically
what we're watching so 2020 this is like
a unique um
uh i think that we're still in the
middle of so so it's still changing
environment 2020 was a very short
recession it's probably the shortest on
on uh a record in that we got two
consecutive quarters of negative gdp
growth
but it was down and right back up and
that's because of uh the intervention by
central banks and politicians with
monetary fiscal policy but correlations
went to one right
and so that was a liquidity crisis where
people were scared they wanted dollars
they didn't want assets they sold them
off everything goes
if you go back to 2008 there was a
six-month liquidity crisis where people
were selling assets gold went down 30 to
the summer of 2008 right then government
stepped in and we went back up and by
2011 gold hit a all-time high
so liquidity crisis can be like super
acute and short like they were in march
of 2020 and april 2020 or they can be
six months you know whatever
in some weird way
it's not like a acute liquidity crisis
but basically what we've been in since
you know november or december of last
year is a version of a liquidity crisis
where people are saying i don't want to
have risk on because i i hear the fed
the fed's in control don't fight the fed
they're going to destroy demand and
they only are going to get more and more
and more bold if inflation stays high
and their actions aren't working which
is where we are in this stagflationary
period
so in some weird way
everyone who is going to sell bitcoin
already has
right now sure there's day trading
there's you know whatever but all of
those hedge funds they all were selling
right you even see tesla like like all
of the people who were looking at this
as one of many assets
they sold it they're like hey look we
need liquidity we need this we're scared
we're whatever
but like it's six set twenty thousand
dollars you know or give or take a
couple thousand dollars on either side
it's because you have a holder base that
like
bitcoin goes to a thousand bucks they're
not selling right and so it's like this
very weird asset because
the more that quantitative easing and
like the debasement and all that stuff
is talked about
the higher bitcoin goes
but bitcoin what it appears given now
doesn't care so much about the actual
inflation as much as the anticipation of
the devaluation in the inflation
okay so people move the assets before it
happens and then once it happens
like inflation's here now right and
everyone's like oh why isn't bitcoin
going up well it's because they're
looking forward and the fed's saying
we're gonna crash everything
right and so what ended up happening is
they crashed everything okay but so does
it imply you're not so worried about
inflation in the future because you see
the price of bitcoin moving
you you see that it's uh moved down i
guess
anticipating and pricing in
the uh the inflation in the future being
brought down by the fed so are you less
worried about inflation now than you
were before i don't think that my
expectations of inflation change based
on what happens to bitcoin's price i
think bitcoin's price changes because of
the expectations of inflation right
which is like a weird nuance but it's
less about like oh i see bitcoin do x
and therefore now i think something
different about inflation it's depending
on what i think is going to happen with
inflation is why bitcoin's price uh
moves but really it's not because of the
inflation as much as it's what is the
federal reserve's response to that
inflation movement so a great example is
uh we're recording this in august of
2022
and uh we just got the cpi print this
morning it came in at 8.5
which is lower than the 9.1 percent from
june there's a lot of people who are
celebrating saying oh my god this is
amazing we now have inflation going down
that's not what happened
month to month inflation was flat
the month-to-month change there was no
change
it's that from
june to july of last year inflation
moved upwards and so now what we're
seeing is base effect
so yes year over year change in
inflation appears to be lower but it's
not because the inflation from june to
july changed it's just because inflation
was going from three to five and then
eventually seven percent in december of
uh 2021. so now we're getting
compounding effects
so if we get to make up numbers let's
say that we get to december of 2022 and
inflation is at seven percent which
people say well we're at 8.5 percent in
the july reading if we get to seven that
means we're heading the right direction
yeah but that means we compounded at
seven percent for two years
you're not getting back the value you
lost like holy [ __ ] by the way like
chipotle is not lowering their prices
right like like no one none of the price
increases are going back yep and so you
have this like really weird thing where
at the end of the day does the number
actually matter like i think that's like
the important question is there a
difference between 8.5 and 9
well like in the official measurements
like it's all kind of manipulated data
right and so if you even look at the cpi
basket itself like this this is
the deeper you go into this the more
you're just like this is all yeah
uh 33
of the cpi basket is made up of
something called shelter
which is estimated right now to be
between five and a half and six percent
year-over-year increase
but rents and real estate are both up 12
or more percent year-over-year
so what goes in the shelter bucket
like how is it that you're counting in
the cpi official measurement
50
or less
of the value of the increase in rent in
real estate like where else are people
if they're not renting if they're not
buying like what else are they doing
right
and so they created all kinds of
[ __ ] metrics like uh
uh owner equivalent rent and like all
this like nonsense
but if you actually go and you read it
and probably one of the scariest things
if you read the cpi methodology
the cpi
rent index is determined based on 1980
census data
and they just call people and there's
like 30 or 60 000 homes that they've
pre-identified based on the 1980 census
data and they rotate through them
right so they maybe call like every ten
thousand every time or whatever and they
just say like hey what what are you
paying for rent
which sounds like okay maybe that's the
best they can do
but we have zillow
apartment.com square like they have real
time data and i think zillow says they
have 100 million data points in real
time
well guess what their red index says in
the teens
right or apartment.com i think it's like
14 i think zillow was like 10 or
something like whatever the numbers are
they're like way higher than what this
is showing yeah and so it begs the
question like is it a data problem is it
a methodology problem
is it a presentation like it's probably
all of it right
but then it comes back to none of that
matters because they're looking at the
cpi metric
and what they're saying is we have
increased interest rates and we are
conducting quantitative tightening and
inflation is persistently high
they're going to keep bringing the
hammer
until one of two things happens either
inflation comes down
or there is so much pain in the economy
that they give up it's politically
impossible
yeah and i think that that's what's
going to happen i think they're going to
give up uh
i'm not predicting what will happen but
i think that they will do it sooner than
people realize because it sounds good to
talk tough
midterm elections
it's gonna be real hard to go into a
midterm election with uh the current
administration saying uh we know that
there's high inflation and we know that
we cost a recession
vote for us yeah yeah yeah uh
what do you think's gonna happen in the
terms that because bloodbath i i
i don't pay attention to like individual
races you know or anything like that in
terms of like who's gonna win this or
this candidate or that candidate uh it's
not interesting
um
but i think that there's a pendulum swim
swing in society where uh we went to one
extreme with uh
there's a bunch of different labels you
could put on it whether it's uh
kind of the the woke stuff for or like
whatever like it's just like it's very
obvious like the pendulum swung one
direction and i think it's swinging back
um
and so just naturally like there's a lot
of people who feel that sentiment shift
i think that's why you see elon musk
jeff bezos like starting to be
talk a lot more about politics and
they just they sense it um
that would likely lead to
you know kind of this like red wave or
whatever in the midterm elections uh but
i always go back on politics of like
presidents really can't do that much
like yes they are the most powerful
person in the world but like people were
really really scared of donald trump and
then people on the other side were
really really scared of joe biden what
have either one of them done
like sure that yes you can point to
specific piece of legislation or
whatever but like
what did they do that like
fundamentally change the course of you
know america and sure the extremes of
both sides will point to certain things
like oh my god can you believe they did
whatever like if you actually look at
like structurally there's checks and
balances
although we for like we we forget that
we like to you know executive powers
like all this stuff whatever
and so it's just really hard for
politicians to like get [ __ ] done which
is also why then i think like the
private market is so responsible for
driving solutions is because like the
bureaucrats
the system is designed for them not to
be able to do [ __ ]
right so we need entrepreneurs to be
able to solve the problems yeah yeah so
it's really interesting if you think
you know people say that the president
is
really powerful but one interesting
question to ask is
what is the difference in outcomes
between one person becoming president
and another person becoming president
and if it's not that much then you then
the question is well who is the person
where if they didn't exist there would
be a big difference
uh where there's a big counter factual
difference i think we said elon musk is
one of those people right like thousand
years best entrepreneurs exactly it's
it's like that that is the biggest
difference to society
if jeff bezos didn't exist you wouldn't
have amazon right if elon musk didn't
exist right like and i don't know how
many are there five people or there are
50 people are there 500 people there's
some number
but almost all of them are
not politicians like i'll say private
sector but like you could say they're
scientists there's you know whatever but
like
they're not politicians
and it goes back to how many of your
smartest friends want to be politicians
they're not my friends
you're just laughing right like nobody
that i know
is like my smartest friends want to be
politicians now
it's not a knock against people who want
to be politicians because actually i
hope that you are somebody's smartest
friend right like actually that's what
we would want um and if you think about
in you know ancient rome and all like it
was a very like aspirational uh thing
but i think in some weird way like meme
culture has destroyed institutions
and like
politicians i mean like look there's
literally twitter accounts that are like
tracking the day trades of a politician
like
it's like this is a joke like you're
just like us like shut up yeah yeah and
so in some weird way um
you you
why would you go do that
if you're intelligent and you could
solve real problems you could make money
you could like do all this stuff like
why would you do it and sure there's
some people who are like oh i believe
that this is the place for change
but there's not very many people who are
like yeah this is the place to create
change yeah i think one of the things
over history that matters a lot is what
do the young talented people want to do
and what are the options for them you'll
always have people in society that are
really ambitious and smart
and
these are the kinds of people who are
like founder types
over but throughout most of history
these were like warlords or you know
military and that was bad for society
obviously right because like being a
warlord is a negative some game i mean
if you think of
somebody like napoleon the guy was
insanely brilliant he was basically uh
he was just today he would be like a
great startup founder um just the
ability to
think about um micromanage the economy
the military the strategy everything
actually there's a funny example where
he tells an austrian diplomat
listen you're not going to win i'm
willing to lose 60 000 men a month right
and i was thinking that's very similar
to if like the uber ceo told the list
ceo you're not going to win i'm willing
to burn a billion dollars a vc capital
quarter well
jeff bezos did this with diaper.com and
others where he literally said i'm just
going to lose money on every diaper i i
uh sell until you sell me your business
right
what was that story with um um can you
remember the japanese investor again
[Music]
was it was it youtube or i forgot the
name of the company but basically he
asked them
uber okay he was uh he was said i want
to give you a hundred million dollars
and they're like we don't need 100
million dollars and he's like okay well
who are your top five competitors and
there they give their names and he's
like okay either you take my money or
i'll give them a hundred million dollars
either want my bazooka pointed at you or
behind you
uh
um yes so yeah but
hopefully over time people the smartest
people will realize
i can make a lot more impact on the
world by pursuing like building
businesses but building goods and
services for people the problem is if
not yeah like you said if none of the
smart people are going into politics you
have a problem where
the biggest impact that politics can
have is preventing people from building
useful goods and services right so if
you think about nuclear is a great
example of this the fda is like um
it's my opinion that a lot of drugs that
could have improved quality of life um
have just basically been
uh
prevented by the fda's long and
convoluted process
so yeah hopefully a few of those kinds
of people actually just like make sure
that things can pass through the
bureaucratic filter you want to hear a
crazy idea go for it one of the fastest
paths to being a celebrity in today's
society is for a young person to become
a politician
like aoc or something yeah
right like they're celebrity politicians
now yeah yeah and and look by the way
i'm always very clear like donald trump
was one afc was one right and so just
like
if you have
congressperson or senator in front of
your name the press will write about you
like you have a fast track to celebrity
and so
the like tick-tock social media
generation
there's a lot of those people are gonna
go try to be politicians yeah right
because it is a path to doing it that's
not all of them but like
the incentives are weird
yeah i do wonder if
like i guess i don't talk to i don't
have like a good sample of people my age
but i do wonder how many of them are
thinking of the world in terms of uh
i want to go into politics and make like
political change the thing is in public
education the stories you're told like
who impacts stories you don't hear of
borla or haber or you know all these
great scientists who have like allowed
billions of people to live you hear
about
you know like activist movements these
movements have been important no doubt
right but if that's your only conception
of history that basically we give people
more rights and that's the only thing
that's changed about history that's our
progress is that's a very incomplete
picture of history and obviously that
reinforces um what people think is
important to do with their careers right
like if that's what you think you're
going to want to become a politician or
something
yeah well and also uh why become a
politician if you can affect more change
in the private market right like like we
celebritize
bezos and musk and you know name all
these people because they're actually
the ones that create change
elon musk and spacex did something that
the us government could not do for way
cheaper and with less time yep it's
insane right and so like okay anderil is
doing something that the us military
could not do right yeah yeah and by the
way like that's a good thing
that we have people who are able to get
capital use their ideas and like provide
these capabilities like it is a good
thing that spacex can bring us the space
it is a good thing that andrew can help
protect the united states of america
right and so like
for the average american we don't give a
[ __ ] who does it i just need somebody to
make sure that like things are good
right
but if the government can't do it then
like we should be really [ __ ] happy
that there's other
solutions out there yeah and then the
the positive uh like the white pillow on
this is you know if you look at the
media they're always
complaining about like people like
moscow bezos but if you look at opinion
polls like pew research uh polls about
what do people think about amazon what
do people think about musk they're
actually like pretty overwhelmingly
positive which means that people
understand that
you use amazon every day right like you
understand like this guy basically is
getting you [ __ ] uh
for very low cost very immediately um
i'm hoping that the narrative that
the media narrative
you know these people are actually just
basically competitors
if you think about like new york times
competitive facebook it's a competitor
to google so obviously they're gonna
have a negative spin hopefully that that
doesn't well they're also a competitor
to the entrepreneurs because the
entrepreneurs uh are able to
uh
basically expose the [ __ ] yeah jeff
bezos in the middle of the pandemic
hired a hundred thousand people yep
right the average pay of an amazon
worker is over 15 hours like 17 an hour
so how is it that jeff bezos was able to
get it to 17 an hour but politicians
can't even do it in their own states let
alone at the federal level right like i
always joke like why are the politicians
under shootings so much why do they only
want fifteen dollars an hour amazon
already pays 17. why don't you make a
17. yeah i mean over time the thing that
drives up wages is higher worker
productivity which is made possible by
innovations that you know make you a
more efficient worker it's like the
people over hype you know
there's also this narrative of oh like
the reason we have better working
conditions today than we did in the past
or we work fewer days and fewer hours is
because of labor market regulations
uh you know like we people say like oh
unions brought us weekends off or stuff
i think the real story is just that like
you're you're just workers are just so
much more productive today that it makes
sense for companies to hire them for
more money if you get more money you're
willing to work if you're you know
you're willing to bargain for weekends
off or stuff like that
um and yeah so i think labor market
regulations have had very little to do
with improvements in
worker conditions over time i think it's
basically been
the free market has just made workers
more efficient and therefore it's good
for workers yeah 100 agree yeah um
let's wrap up yeah where can we send
people to uh to find you on the internet
yes so i have a podcast
called the lunar society i have
intellectuals scientists founders come
on and i really like to learn a lot
about their discipline ask them
um really nuanced interesting deep
questions i've had uh samuel good free
david deutsch talaka and those kinds of
people on a very wide variety of folks
and also very kind of deep uh
intelligent conversations with them yeah
thank you uh and where can people find
it yes it's called the lunar society it
can be found everywhere a fine podcast
or sold no it's free uh and it's
it you so
apple podcast spotify youtube there's a
video version on youtube so
that you can find that there and we've
been talking about some of my blog posts
those you can find on my sub stack
dwarkashpatel.com difficult name but if
you look at the description you'll see
what my i just want my name so just go
to the orchestra.com
and yeah i'm dwarkash underscore sp on
twitter but the lunar society podcast is
my main thing so i'm just gonna speak
slowly because i tend to speak fast the
lunar society yeah
we'll uh we'll link to it in the uh in
the description uh i enjoy it so i
appreciate you coming in thank you and
anyone who hasn't yet uh i highly
suggest go check out uh check out the
podcast or follow you on twitter as well
yeah man well dude i really appreciate
you having me on i i really enjoy your
content so i was super super grateful to
be able to come up with only only for
three hours or so
yeah i didn't feel that long at all
all right we'll definitely do it again
in the future yeah man
awesome